All right guys.
I had to do this real quick announcement at the top because we added some big
shows that I have to tell you about.
Uh,
so before we get into the show,
here's what it is.
June 2nd in Chicago,
we added a fourth show,
um,
at the Chicago theater.
It's on sale now.
August 15th,
we added a second show in Toronto at the Sony Center that is on sale now,
August 17th in Vancouver at the Queen Elizabeth.
That second show is going on sale.
Friday the 19th of April,
September 28th,
we added a second show in Denver at the Belko that goes on sale.
Thursday,
April 18th and in Minneapolis we added a second show,
um,
October 11th that goes on sale this Friday the 19th.
Additionally in the UK,
the dates there that had withheld tickets for all the presales have now released
tickets.
So if you weren't able to get tickets,
I got a lot of messages about it.
You can get tickets now.
Uh,
they're all at Thompson girl,
Tom [inaudible],
Tom cigarette.com/tour.
That's my website and I know it well.
All right.
That is it.
Now let's get into the show.
This episode
of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress,
the only online mattress company to provide free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Wow.
Christina?
Yeah,
I think a
Colby one they sent us the library is a library of stuff.
A library.
It's great.
It's amazing what a talent that ob one is.
Yes.
I am full of gratitude because the so far 51,
I think soon to be 55 city,
second half of the take it down tore is up and running.
Okay.
It's all on sale now.
Thomson [inaudible] dot com slash tour.
I couldn't be more thrilled.
Um,
and thankful to be doing this in all the places I'm doing it.
And um,
added like some crazy things,
man.
I'm going to your homeland.
I'm going to Budapest.
I can't believe it.
Going to Paris,
Berlin,
London.
I'm going to Dublin.
Wow.
And I'm also going all over the u s I'm doing Canadia,
Winnipeg,
Calgary,
Toronto and London.
London,
Ontario,
Ontario.
Both.
I'm doing both.
Anyways.
They're all
on sale now.
Thanks very much everybody.
I really appreciate it.
Can't wait to come to your city,
uh,
and,
and bring the show to you.
International genes,
international genes.
Exciting.
I want to thank everybody who came to it's too late now for that,
isn't it?
When does this air,
this is coming out next week.
Oh No,
thanks for coming to Minneapolis tits.
Anyways.
Yeah.
Uh,
five sold out.
Show sold out.
Well in advance.
I cannot thank you guys enough.
Every show I've done on the road has been sold out in 2019,
which is a miracle and it's beyond my wildest imagination,
so thank you.
May 10th and 11th.
I'm doing a Tempe,
Arizona.
The Tempe Improv.
May 31st through June 1st sperm bank.
That's Burbank,
California flappers comedy club.
June 20th through 22nd Washington DC at the Washington Dick come Improv ticket
links are on Christina up he online.
And also,
if you haven't seen it,
cash me outside on Netflix.
I'm home here now.
Check out my two specials.
Mother inferior and the degenerates.
I was eight months pregnant when I did the degenerates sealing fall on you.
You're dead.
That's hot.
Fucking unbearably hot.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah,
so I think by the time this comes out,
I'm coming to Boston.
If you haven't gotten tickets,
Austin.
Oh,
and it guys be do your shopping on Amazon.
You could go through our banner on your mom's house,
podcast.com.
You could click on the banner at the bottom of the homepage,
your shopping as you normally would.
Gene,
there's so much to talk.
How?
My Gosh,
oh my.
Oh my.
I have so many things to share.
I was so many fun things around the corner.
I can't wait.
I've,
I'm really excited to do today.
Shit.
All right,
let's get into it.
Let's do it.
A little tiny picker.
Got that shirt.
That is your Dick.
You proud of your whole fucking Dick,
but it's your car.
You can't get it up.
Christina,
do you know like 25 times this weekend?
I listened to that young Patriot on ob tone.
I know.
It's really good.
I mean,
it's
a young patriot.
Put It on Spotify so people have to type in to find it.
I think young is y,
U N G and then Patrion ta te Reo ends called Cool Guy Club,
so look up young patriarch,
Cool Guy Club.
It's on there.
It's tremendous.
It really is.
They really know.
I'll be ones on that one.
He made the,
he produced this unbeatable team.
Those two guys.
Yeah.
That's such a good song.
So many revelations you guys.
But first of all,
that opening clip.
Oh yeah.
I mean why does shit always happen at the home depot?
Home Depot has a lot of shit going on and most of it's in the parking lot.
I know it kind of is.
Yeah.
I avoid going to it for that reason because a,
the home depot so enormous,
they're just so big and cavernous.
You always lost.
The great irony is that the worst is that like they have everything and like no
one can help.
No help.
You're just on your own.
I went there one time looking for something,
I think,
I dunno,
a tool or something and I ran in this guy.
I was like,
I'm looking for this and he like,
ah,
I work in plants.
I was like,
plants.
yeah,
there's a whole now Terry and whatever it's called.
And he's like,
you need a like a Bush or a tree or say,
Oh man,
I want,
I want like a hammer.
And he's like,
that's not my department.
And then you just look,
it looks like an airport hangar behind.
It's tremendous.
Or even like one time I tried to buy paint and I just,
I just started crying.
I'm like,
there's just too many things to choose from.
God forbid you want somebody to mix the color for it's,
it's just,
that's why you're like you really hopeless.
That's why you really appreciate,
uh,
awesome.
Um,
customer service people.
Cause they're not everywhere.
They change your life.
Yeah.
I think that's why people go crazy in the parking lot because they've been in
the home depot for an hour.
They feel lost.
They feel alone.
They feel confused.
I just had a,
I had an almost meltdown the other day.
And the Home Depot?
No,
with Fedex.
I have a FedEx account.
I'm a huge fan of,
no,
I am,
but here's what happened.
So you know,
I'm home,
I press,
I'm home here now.
I've press two labels.
I print two labels.
Yeah,
but I'm in a separate room than the printer.
So when I go to the printer,
there's nothing there and I realize,
oh,
we have a new printer so I have to,
you know,
align it with,
right.
With the Wifi and the computers.
Sprinters are another,
how do you think they can just ever just make a printer that you just need,
just turn it on and it just fucking prince.
They're like,
all right,
you have the latest software upgrades.
You're like,
I dunno.
No paper to go through it.
So,
so annoying.
When I go back to my laptop,
the last thing that I have printed,
the last label still there after I connect them and I'm able to reprint it,
I print it.
I'm like,
okay,
what about the previous one?
The one that I closed,
I printed two labels,
so I'm at the Fedex site and I'm like,
okay,
there's gotta be a way that you can see what you printed and then reprint it,
right.
I go,
I'm like,
I'll go through the shipping stuff.
I go to the uh,
tracking.
I'm like,
oh,
it probably be in the tracking.
And then you could pull up the label.
I'm not kidding you.
I spent half an hour,
I then Google I youtube how to reprint the format that's in the youtube video is
not the current format.
So I'm losing my fucking mind.
I go to Fedex with the,
you know,
the label that I have,
I want,
here you go.
And I tell the guy,
he goes,
we can't do that.
You can't do what?
We can't pull up your account.
I have it.
I go,
I'm explaining to you my issue.
He goes,
yeah,
we can't pull up any of your stuff and we can't do whatever you did on your,
we have no access to any of it.
Like that's what he leads with.
I'm like,
so what if I were to log into my head,
cause you can't do this here.
You can't,
nothing,
nothing you want to do,
I could help you with.
And I'm like,
all right man,
it's the worst.
And then I'm like,
so there's just no way when I'm explaining is is accessible or possible,
I can have you talked to our manager.
I'm like,
all right.
Then I see.
I'm like,
where's the,
and then he looks right.
He's like,
I don't know,
but she's an assistant manager.
I'm like,
all right.
So I go up to her and I,
I'm,
of course,
I tell her I'm just super frustrated,
but I tell her calmly,
I go,
you know,
I just went through this whole thing.
I tell her,
I tell her the whole thing that I just told you,
but I go and I just don't know what she goes,
do you know you can you log into your account here?
And I go,
yeah.
So I log in and sh,
and the secret is that the reprint is in,
is under create a shipment.
So like if you were to start a new shipment,
you'd go create a shipment.
You click that.
Then the reprint thing is in there.
So she's like,
it's kind of like counterintuitive,
but she's super nice about it and I go,
you're just like,
you know,
relieve my whole stress and,
and thank you so much.
You know,
she was very nice.
She actually was like a,
she goes by the way she had finished.
She goes,
I love your stuff.
I'm like,
oh,
thanks a lot.
And then as I'm walking out,
another guy goes,
hey man,
um,
you're,
you're the comedian.
I go,
yeah.
He goes,
you've really gotten better.
And I go,
thanks.
And he goes,
yeah,
you just kind of way more polished now.
I used to listen to you all the time.
I was like,
okay,
thanks Pam for the critique at the Fed and that's wonderful.
But how fucking stupid is it to have a reprint of something standard create.
Even hearing you say it,
it makes me,
it gives me
anxiety and it makes me mad that I'm wasting time in my life.
Even fucking thinking about stuff like that.
It's pretty bad.
It's terrible.
Um,
anyways,
can I,
this woman's amazing.
She's clearly mentally ill,
right?
Yeah.
Are we going to go for mental illness or drugs on this one?
Definitely not on drugs.
She's a,
and also she's completely unreasonable for people listening or even watching.
She's upset at the car parked next to her saying it's too close.
And she's the one that parked out of line.
All of the words she parked off of,
out of the two lines.
Yeah.
And she's mad at the guy who parked correctly,
who's now too close to her because of how she parked.
Yeah.
She's definitely just start.
Is there any more of her there is,
right?
Yeah.
I mean she's,
yeah.
She's like,
you should go to your car.
My daughter has to get in.
No,
you did dummy.
Yeah.
Well let me,
let me tell you something about this too.
She parties,
I can close.
This is the difference because this woman really needs to get checked.
Okay.
And if she were a guy,
she would already have had her ass kicked in her life a number of times with
this attitude.
Yep.
This is where at least another woman needs to put her in a choke hold or shower
rods.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Because she's,
she's so,
she's so entitled and,
and,
and throws this fucking attitude of the wound and,
and people allow it.
There's some guys would be like,
all right,
I'll move my car.
And she really just needs a woman.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
To throw an elbow.
Her man,
you and I discussed this yesterday,
is that that's how boys and men resolve conflicts is physically women just don't
resolve conflict that way.
Well,
when you've been checked as a guy,
you don't go,
so what would you do if this were you?
You wouldn't even say anything.
He'd be like,
all right,
well
if you're,
if I was this woman,
first of all,
it's,
you know,
it takes a fraction of a second to realize that she's Adeline with how she
parked.
Yeah.
And then to make unreasonable demands on top of that.
I mean,
as a guy,
I don't know,
I'm just,
I'm not insane.
So I would just be like,
I know I'd be out at like I maybe I don't want to move my car.
Maybe it's humiliating to have to move my car.
But knowing if there's another guy there who's like,
I didn't do anything wrong.
Part of your,
your,
your DNA wiring as a guy starts to just automatically size up who's telling you.
Of course you don't have the right like a guy fucking is like,
hey dude,
your,
your brain just goes like,
can this guy fuck me up?
Yeah.
But that's cause you,
cause you guys are apes and you resolve conflict by hitting each other.
That's true.
So I'm saying there's a value in that.
There is a value in that physical violence there is there.
I agree with you.
No,
Yeah.
Because you don't start bullshit like this and parking lots because you know
some guys going to beat your ass so there's no,
exactly.
And then Shari around shit mark if she's fucking 70 [inaudible] around for a
whole fucking money now.
And that's what I want to be clear.
I didn't say a guy should do anything to her.
He shouldn't a woman,
she'd kick her ass.
I wish women are,
you say you're advocating that women should start violence with each other?
I think sometimes I think it's good.
Yeah.
You know,
kind of makes you had it kind of makes you second guessed saying stupid shit.
That's what,
that's what it does.
It does.
I'll tell you something,
cause I don't do this in public for a reason because I've been in fights with,
I shouldn't say right loosely that I've been beaten up.
Yeah.
I have not successfully won a fight.
So I know not to flip shit to strangers.
Even almost getting your ass kicked makes you aware of the physical danger of,
of watching your stupid fucking mouth.
Yeah.
You know?
Well she just never been hit.
So you're saying is this bench needs to get hit a couple of times?
Yeah.
By a lady.
I should hit her.
Yeah.
Does she do this a lot?
Is She okay?
No,
she's fine.
She's not fine.
You're not fine.
Do you see your tire?
Let's give serious.
Yeah.
Look,
it gets serious.
You see the line that separates these tires.
Now come over here.
Come over here.
Come on.
This is just for fun.
And then look at this.
I mean,
she's out of her fucking mind.
Yeah,
she's wrong.
Oh,
for tire is right on that one.
You need to stay within the lines,
but look,
look,
I'm perfectly the line.
I'm actually hugging this side a little too much.
And then her,
she was not helping is her daughter with her little panda backpack.
A grown ass woman.
I know.
Fucking child's backpack is siding with her mom.
What happened to Tom the half to know if your mom was doing this nonsense?
I'd be like,
mom,
no,
I've done shit.
My mom has done shit like this pops off at the mouth all the time.
You should have gotten her ass years ago.
But I,
we've all,
my mom's kids,
we've all been like,
mom,
the fuck are you talking about?
Can you know?
And like,
that's usually how this picture is that the logical person goes,
mom,
fuck you dad should have hit your mom a little bit more.
No,
no,
that's not what I was saying.
[inaudible] loca back you.
Oh Mary,
go
crazy fucker.
You crazy.
It's my mom right there.
100%.
No,
it was shit.
You're fucking,
oh bitch,
you,
I'm in a car like that asshole.
You're not happy,
man.
Oh,
sorry.
I am.
Yeah.
To be driving a car like that.
I'm in disbelief.
This is something,
a little tiny picker.
This is the need that that is.
Your Dick isn't yet.
You proud of your own fucking Dick,
but it's your car that you can't get it up by.
I got my ass.
You get him off by them in a woman.
No,
I'm not fighting.
I'm fighting with a woman.
You
Eh,
you stupid shit.
So insane.
It gives me anxiety.
Northern California.
Yeah,
it looks like it.
I'm only saying this because she's Asian.
I would say.
Yeah,
like Morin County.
And what are you,
what's your,
why are you saying he's Asian?
I agree.
It's not la.
I don't feel like it's Alhambra.
Only because,
or Monterey Park Asians
are
it a Chinese guy for 40 year.
Everywhere there was.
It was like,
yeah,
but that's where you go for good Chinese because that's where they are now.
Because then she'd have an accent.
This could be fucking Dallas anywhere,
but I just,
my my Asian instinct.
It is right.
It's Chino.
Oh,
I'm not finding it all.
Sounds good.
So that's why I guess northern California,
because he sounds homosexual.
What?
He sounds like a gay guy.
He sounds like a guy like a gay guys.
Sound good to you?
Of course.
Listen
to this guy would beat you up.
This guy 100% no,
no.
Cause
yeah,
he's not even aggressive man.
No,
he's not aggressive.
Like,
I can't take this anymore.
I'll take you down.
You set up a pitch that's threatening,
but it's not,
but it's not.
He sounds like the [inaudible] guy.
He could be.
You know what I would do though,
because this bitch is about to walk into home depot is just park a little bit
closer to her car.
Credible inches,
closer difference between Tom and me is that I do not encourage unnecessary
conflict.
Unnecessary.
You love it.
You love the Instagram fights.
I posted something very controversial,
my account at the Christina p on Instagram and you went after bitches like crazy
and I was like,
I'm out.
I'm just here to enjoy the ride it fun.
It's fun.
That's why we're married.
I kept having fantasies about knowing that someone that we're breaking down
mentally
got about them crying at home.
Yeah.
Okay.
Listen,
fucking armpit hair.
All right.
Listen,
I have been dying to share this with you.
You got to pay attention and he full attention.
Phones down.
As you know,
I did this last weekend at the Acme Comedy Club in Minneapolis tits and just so
people know,
the reason that things are sometimes there's an intro separated the touring,
he's kind of wild and we don't ever want to miss a week,
so we have to record things separately from win.
Right.
And tomorrow where it's a lot.
Yeah,
it's a lot.
Oh,
something's coming out here.
Okay.
Anyways,
I did this weekend and mini apple tits and I had this wonderful opener named
Ahmed Colloff.
Okay.
He goes by Somalian,
s o m o l l y.
A N on Instagram.
Give him a shout out because he's a black guy and he said,
I,
we were talking about though,
tried out guy.
Yeah.
And he goes,
it's homey on now.
I got it.
It's not homey on out.
We've done this before.
He goes,
it's only an hour.
And listened to me because he is talking to black guys who liked to fuck and
fuck good.
The audience he's addressing,
they are black guys and black guys would say,
homie on out,
hello man out.
I mean,
hello,
does not blow your mind right now.
Well,
no,
I mean I,
I thought that was always one of the theories on,
on it.
I never thought of it that way.
That who he's speaking to their black men.
So therefore the phrasing he would use would be like,
uh,
you know,
black men all Minnow Holla man out.
He's,
he's,
he's street.
You know what I mean?
You're trying to like
Holly Holm man out.
I know,
I know.
It's,
it's,
look,
I mean,
it's the fucking Zapruder film,
man.
It's study it for generations.
The only,
there was some way to confirm what he was saying.
I know,
I know this mystery man.
But anyway,
I was blown away,
but I thought it was pretty interesting.
I thought I would,
you know,
it's a great,
it's a,
it is a great contribution to the analysis of what is said there.
I've always been most leaning into either home here,
now we're home,
Ya know,
it's either how I think it's not,
it's how a man out on minnow or I'm,
I'm home here now.
Now the reason being he's addressing black guys,
but he's also referring to his address and when he's clearly saying like,
this is the address,
come over,
do these things to me.
I'm home here now.
Make sense?
I'm just saying it could be,
you know,
I know the debates go on.
I get message all the time.
Sometimes when people sign up and they'll go,
by the way,
it's,
it's homey on it.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
it'll be their sign off to a message about,
it's one of the world's greatest mysteries,
mysteries and what,
we may never know the truth,
but for now I'm going to have fun speculating.
I like it.
Um,
by the way,
before we go any further,
I want to make it clear that we are thrilled to be,
um,
doing this podcast here and in the new space in our studio so to speak.
And uh,
I want to encourage you if you have not to check out the two other podcasts,
we are currently producing the honeydew Ryan sicklers podcast,
which is fantastic.
I know,
um,
audio releases on Mondays.
The video goes up on Tuesdays on,
on this youtube channel.
You can look up the honeydew and download it,
subscribe everywhere,
podcasts are available.
And of course,
Dr Drew's podcast,
doctor drew after dark.
That audio comes out on Thursdays and the video is up on Fridays on this youtube
channel.
The why mh youtube channel.
That show has been exploding.
I'm wildly popular out of the gate and thank you very much for supporting it.
I loved drew.
I love that his show is doing so well with sickle cell too.
Wonderful.
Yeah.
Well that was just,
just getting started.
It's going to,
it's going to get bigger and bigger.
Um,
I just did a hot ones,
truth or DAB,
which is their spinoff show.
Cool.
Think it is about if,
if it's,
uh,
based on the schedule talking to them,
um,
as,
as this podcast comes out that might be hitting youtube right then or maybe it's
the week after I did it with Bertrand.
Um,
and the concept,
man,
it is rough.
That one really fucked me up.
So when you do hot ones,
you do progressively hotter wings.
So he start with one and then,
you know what I mean?
It's mild,
it gets a little bit spicier and then you build up truth.
Or Dav is like truth or dare.
But if you don't want to tell the truth,
the only thing,
the only option is you eat a wing with the spiciest.
So you start at a 10.
My God,
that's great.
I was crying and sweat.
And it sounds like you took a lot of dabs.
Oh yeah,
man.
I mean he was asking you things,
you're like,
I can't fucking answer this shit.
I was on the phone with you yesterday or whenever it was you finished felony.
I was on the road and you're like,
I got shit,
I got it.
Go Sean's new show and I have to go take a dump.
Dude.
I had a couple of shifts in me.
Um,
it's cool because they do a,
you do do owes.
So,
um,
uh,
they had,
Tiffany Haddish love Kevin Hart,
Burt and I think there's another one and we're talking about like,
be good for like other comedy Duos to go into,
you know,
like,
I dunno shop,
I probably do it.
Oh,
he'd be great.
Yeah.
But like it's like you do it with like Callin or he's got that other a show with
the mouse guy and then there's like,
um,
I don't know if like maybe my favorite murder that's two hosts,
you know,
Karen and Georgia I think is her name.
So there's all these like combos.
But it's like,
it's a hilarious concept because when you're eating that you actually get into a
delirium.
It's like doing shots.
So the further along the show gets,
you're so uncomfortable that he asks you something and he might just spit
something out.
I'm glad I'm not doing,
I mean spit out like a thought.
Oh yeah.
Cause you're like,
you're so uncomfortable and you're like,
what a great show.
Thank you Sean.
It's really funny.
It's really fun.
Yeah.
People love it.
Anyways,
so we went to a Laker game last night.
Yup.
And I could not stop licking my chops.
It was really,
really awful.
Was at school that hadn't takes like that.
You were really,
I was really licking my chops.
Um,
now here's the deal.
Oh,
here's your Instagram account.
Yeah.
You posted a few videos of us yesterday at the game.
That's what the,
uh,
you want to show it.
This is what the,
well,
that one's,
yeah,
that one's Christina.
Right there.
There's the guys warming up and we'll look at Christina.
Just licking her lips.
Believable man.
And then drip daddy dollars right there.
Check out.
This is a,
this Laker girls,
right there are girls.
And then you turn right there and look at me.
Just look looking at,
I chop so dumb.
And then there you are with your ridiculous,
listen,
my friend Dion [inaudible] fresh [inaudible] tell you that my ancestors,
my relatives would be so stoked on your top.
The Nice top Tommy.
This is a good jacket.
Very nice.
Very expensive looking jacket.
This is,
you're making every eastern blocker proud homie.
Yeah.
I love this book.
I love it.
Hey Man,
I'm so excited that you're filing number.
We ran into that dude.
Did you buy that?
Hey,
yeah,
yeah.
Very nice jacket.
Very expensive.
Looks very nice to me.
Good work.
Yeah,
color is very expensive.
Nice patterns.
Nice pattern.
A very good,
you need the gold chain.
That's what everybody says.
Any and everybody said the gold chain is what's missing man.
Yeah.
So we went to the Laker game.
It's Super Fun.
I was very disappointed though because Lebron was not playing last night.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's got some injury and I had same cause he's not going to,
well first of all,
as we all know,
I Lebron's amazing to watch.
So I like that.
And I feel like he has one of the biggest hogs on the team.
Compression shorts or not.
I feel like I see it moving,
swinging,
working.
What?
Yeah.
And I was kind of disappointed in how many white guys there were on the court.
It was the Utah Jazz.
Yeah.
Lotta honkies by law they have to have like seven white guys.
What are you talking about in,
uh,
in Utah?
That's a,
it's actual law.
Why?
Because of the population demographics and they feel like there's a
disproportionate number of white guys on the team that they have to have more
white guys in their sports racist.
It's a little,
it's a pretty controversial thing.
Should be,
that's stupid be who's ever the best know.
They don't care.
They're like,
no,
it's gotta be some more white guys.
Same thing.
You know,
if you look at their college teams,
Byu,
they have like a lot of white guys.
Oh that's terrible.
It's terrible.
And it's terrible for the fans.
It's also a completely made up.
It's not true.
So
he got it.
But,
but there were a lot of white guys playing with these discount tickets.
Didn't like it at all.
Yeah.
Cause you know they're not carrying shit in their pants.
That's not why we watch basketball.
It's not why you watch basketball.
Just care about the dicks.
That's horse.
Why do you think I liked them?
Box seats.
I want to get the floor seats.
No,
no.
I got to keep you off the floor or at least take a Lola like a sauce pan.
Hold under your mouth for all the drool you're going to be at.
I loved it.
You can't really see junk though.
You can't win when Lebron run.
No,
you can.
I can.
I got my binoculars.
I looked down on their bringing in a suit.
You can see why I liked to look.
Dude,
he was wearing his suit but he had those big old clown shoes on.
Did you see that?
He was wearing nice sneakers but they look like fucking clown shoes cause of how
big his feed our.
Hey,
what do you think?
I think they're probably a pretty big L.
My God.
Hell Yeah Dude.
Those fools out that big.
His penis.
Jesus Christ.
You know what I love so much at the Laker Games,
it's my favorite thing.
When they put the people in the audience on the big jumbo tron thing and they
get to see themselves.
I could watch that all day.
So I was 15 lily that foot.
Well,
yeah,
I mean Uber from a basketball player.
Mangled.
Oof.
Yeah.
That's the price.
That's the cost for being the boss.
Damn homie.
Cool.
How much to put those totes?
He's in your mouth talking,
speaking to Tutsis next to some nice.
You gotta bring that a blue band.
You're going to die again.
It's on my Instagram account.
The Christina p look at it.
You're going to die.
So I get on first class.
Ah,
I'm going to Barf.
I'm in a fucking vomit again.
It's sat next to you,
dude.
I was sitting next to this guy.
This is in first class.
He s he comes in all lumbering that you really let people know because people
were like,
oh,
that's what you get for being in coach.
I'm like,
bitch,
I don't fly coach.
And then
he came in and wheezing and he had a huge fucking pot belly,
like a booze bag belly and he was like,
and then he sits down next to me and I see this.
So he's wearing a flip flop and it looks like half a compression sock and his
feet are just all different colors.
The toes are different colors and then the big toenail is rotting off.
It's got a green gang.
It looks like gang green.
How much,
how much to put them in your mouth,
how much Lebron's or his foot?
Lebron's all day.
Why?
Because there was no fungus or like on the bronze.
It didn't look like it really looked pretty jacked.
Well,
who's fault would you put in your mouth?
This guy or Lebron's yellow Brown
anyways,
and then he wreaks of booze.
It's the morning,
of course he orders more alcohol and then he tells me he's a missionary and he
goes,
I'm going.
I just came from the Philippines and no,
I'm flying into Uganda.
I'm like,
I wouldn't with those open sores on your feet,
you nasty as hell.
He should wear some closed toe shoes to Uganda.
Don't you think?
Can you believe this fool got on a plane like this,
bro?
People are fucking crazy.
Open ceilings.
Worse
that tank tops.
That's disgusting.
Armpits out,
chest out,
Chin armpit flakes everywhere.
Crazy people are so disrespectful.
I mean,
I think even a guy tell you as a city dweller,
I think wearing flip flops in the street is inappropriate to begin with.
If you live in a major city,
dude,
you could step on needles,
cockroaches,
vomit dog shit.
But to get on a plane with your feet out,
it's just,
it's not hygienic.
It's not cool.
It's not cool to other people,
right?
It's just disrespectful.
I know people are going to be like big risky and you need people who flip flops.
I don't fucking care.
It's gross.
It's nasty,
nasty,
bro.
That's airborne.
All that nasty shit.
I'm sitting right now and I'm like,
oh my God,
and he wants to talk to me.
Oh,
it's so fucking gross.
I hate everybody.
Don't you just hate everybody?
Well,
this is what makes commercial travel.
Air travel in America is just,
it's God disgust.
It's like a greyhound bus and know,
you know,
he's got it together.
The Asians,
they deal,
they fly more respectful.
I'm serious.
I was in the,
I was in Hong Kong,
Singapore.
It's just like a different culture of like nobody boards would like,
there's got to stink.
That's God just pissed on myself,
but I got a flood.
No one's like that.
Well let's,
they treat you like really nice in economy,
like a flu,
a Cathay Pacific,
which is like the,
the big airline,
uh,
think it's Hong Kong's airline.
Yeah.
And you know,
the flight attendants treat you.
We flew economy,
like civilized people and really nice and they served you meals in economy.
It's nice.
Really,
really nice.
Very good.
So there was that,
um,
oh,
I have a submission for you.
Um,
this is from a guy on Instagram.
He DMD me.
It goes by Jibo hone.
J Ibba.
He suggested a name for women who have sex with comedians.
Oh,
what is it?
Ready?
Yeah,
a joker poker.
That's pretty good.
That's um,
so also kind of g-rated.
It's it,
it's not as disgusting as a giggle.
Gash.
Like Josh Potter propels the good one.
Google gosh is good.
That's not good.
It is good.
It's nasty.
Um,
by the way,
[inaudible] all a bottle of La Blah blah blah.
Um,
the water champ water bottle sold out of course
best.
So we reordered.
It should back in the store.
Uh,
Dr Drew's,
you shouldn't prolapse your anus shirt also sold very well.
Thank you for supporting it because the water champ thing is so big.
People like it so much.
We have water champ,
your mom's house socks.
So that we've been doing these socks for about a year.
Different logos.
There's like bikes,
one Dj,
Dad Mouth Piss on me,
beat me.
And now water champ.
These are awesome.
So those are in the store.
Thank you very much for your support.
Those are really cool.
Um,
yeah,
piss on me.
Beat me homie.
On is Christ.
Oh my God,
this is Christina.
Hello.
I'm available.
That's Christina right there.
Laker game.
I recorded 10,
10,
10.
Um,
did you mention the ID?
I have it yet.
So,
oh my God,
you guys,
mommies,
you think you're a die hard mommy of the show.
You think you love your mom's house.
I met a couple this weekend and this is insane.
And Mama Soda,
I've never heard,
I could not believe this is real.
I know in many apple tits.
I'm Assan and Isabella [inaudible].
Is there a last name?
There are a married couple.
And they had their legal middle names changed to be jeans.
And I'm not even kidding.
And I said,
could you please send me a copy of your ID card?
And I looked at it and I even asked to be verified that this is a real id card
by the,
um,
whatever the security guy there isn't yet believe these two,
diehard mommy's had their middle names legally changed to genes.
Isn't that bananas?
Yeah,
we've got a,
we've got to get in touch with them.
I know they,
they email me,
so I have their email.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean,
I feel like we have to send them a swag bag.
Oh,
at the least.
If you,
uh,
change your name legally to an inside joke from this podcast,
you're getting a shirt bra.
That's wild.
Tell me what a hassle it is to change your name.
Yeah,
and it takes a lot of social security office.
DMZ motion.
Thank you very much.
Yes,
I'm Isabella and Exxon.
Exxon,
Exxon.
Thank you.
So cute.
Yeah,
I couldn't believe that.
That's a first.
I've never seen that one.
I knew mom's house.
Oh,
you know who that lady was about to fight.
Do you have that other group fight that we were going to have you seen this
fight?
This shit was crazy,
man.
This was like a,
I think it's in a parking garage and there's all this where,
I don't know why.
Fights always happened in parking.
Yeah.
Parking areas.
I pretty sure this is a garage.
Well,
it's infuriating to park and drive.
Ay.
Yay.
Right.
It was the George Perez.
Oh,
you mean shotgun?
God.
Oh my God.
What is that?
She's,
she's using it as a weapon guys.
She's using it as,
oh my,
how dare you put this in our file.
Take this off.
You did it.
I didn't do it.
I guess it did you ask him to no idea.
I swear I do worst.
Turn it off.
God Tom,
I really didn't do that.
I swear I didn't ask him.
Ask Him.
He just asked him to pull up the footage.
You showed it to me.
Yeah.
So you knew that there was barf.
I thought that there might be
no,
I was the one that,
that prepped everything.
Christina,
I'm not listening to you talk.
You're now a trader.
Blue Man.
It's over baby.
It's not.
And I know you guys tricked me.
There's to be another one.
I'm going to put my ear buds and it's more barfs going to happen.
No,
it's not.
It's fine.
You swear.
Yes.
I promise I won't touch your painter for like a month if you like
promise.
Okay,
go ahead.
Okay.
What's with the genes?
All right.
Um,
and by the way,
um,
few weeks ago we introduced the idea of we have the sponsor manscape that has
all this great stuff.
Yes.
Ball trimmers and ball wipes and it has like bodywash all this stuff.
Anyways,
they sent me a second kit.
They sent two of them.
No.
So I discussed with you guys that we would have a little contest amongst the
staff here about who gets the second one.
But do you guys have an idea for how to do it?
I mean we've been thinking,
uh,
you know,
whoever has uh,
the longest strand of hair that needs manscaping was probably a good way to
decide who needs it.
I like it.
That is the grossest thing I've ever heard.
Are you not embarrassed to show like me or longest pure?
What was that like?
Cause I know I'm going to lose.
No,
I'm not going to get it.
So are you going to do,
are we going to do photos of your pubic area
photos,
photos of her pubic area?
I mean,
I thought we were just yet.
God a strand.
Oh,
Tom.
As the judge has to take a measuring tape to it.
Oh.
And then make sure I know it will be double placebo so you won't know whose is
who.
Ah,
are you sure you want to do this?
Oh,
it's really disgusting.
I think we'll know.
Whose is whose,
I mean one of you is a red hair Jewish guy.
Do your,
does your Judaism showing your pubes the chair does town.
It does.
Yeah.
He's very curly.
Okay.
And then is there is a,
is everyone gonna participate?
Um,
I think it's good
here in this room.
It's going to be either me,
Chris or,
or potter.
And I mean my money's on pot.
I mean,
here's the thing.
When can we get our sea?
Those pubes ban we're really trying to do,
we can do it in the break if you want and we can announce next week.
Wow.
That'd be really great.
I can't wait to do it on the show though.
Looking at the pubes and you deciding,
well,
I mean right now that we'd have to like stop.
You're going to pull your pubes at break.
Yeah.
And then you're going to bring the pubes and like between this week and next
week.
Next week,
yeah.
Yeah.
We will have a pubes that Tom will have personally measured him.
Ah,
you got to do it on the show.
You have to measure them on.
Oh yeah,
of course.
I mean the audience wants to be,
I want them.
I went to pubes taped to a piece of
paper and a ruler.
Yeah.
It'll be put a number of tape over it.
It'll be like person a person B person c will have no idea who's a zoo.
And you see how he didn't gender it?
Yeah,
I love that.
Well,
there's three persons in there,
right?
You know,
nice persons.
Um,
all right.
And you guys are so nasty.
You're going to have to measure their dirty pubes Tommy,
it's cool.
I have a long tongue.
Who's pubes are you most afraid of?
Why?
Wait,
why do you,
Josh is asking why you think they're all dirty.
Do Cause you guys are all nasty.
You guys are all nasty.
Yeah,
I mean your dudes.
So I'll dudes are just now I would say of the three of you,
the pubes I would want,
yeah.
What is the that 10
most want to to least,
okay,
let's go buy hygiene.
I'm just going on hygiene.
I'm not going to go on anything else other than like my perceived what?
Hygiene level.
Right.
I'm going to go third place.
Potter.
Right is an SS.
The nastiest.
He's nasty.
He's a nasty ass.
Oh my God,
you guys are so disgusting.
Josh just said that he shampoos his dick and it's very effective.
Very offended that you think is the 30th I Bet Josh Watch that.
Well cause he gets,
he actually gets me sticking it in everywhere.
Yeah,
but that doesn't mean anything sometimes.
Okay.
So number two,
I'm going to go with the blue band.
Okay.
And then first place is Chris.
He's the cleanest.
I think Chris is the cleaner.
He's real happy about that.
I've caught whiffs of him and he smells nice.
Really?
I haven't smelled a youtube.
I'm not smelled you too,
so I don't know.
Well they're both smoke machines tell that's what it,
yeah.
Josh schmucks way more than me though.
So he definitely smells worse.
Yeah,
no,
I'll agree on that.
The cigarettes make you smell.
Yeah.
You said,
what was my Dick?
Has he come yet?
That's Josh come yet Josh had become yet.
No,
he says,
no,
God,
nothing has helped at all.
If you guys want an update,
should he be yeah.
Do you guys sure.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
because last time we spoke,
Josh had mentioned like a trauma and that he remembered what?
Yeah.
And I,
we need some more clarification,
Josh memory,
you mentioned a trauma thing.
Yeah.
No,
I,
uh,
had a revelation with doctor drew.
This just happened in that conversation with him.
Yeah.
He came up,
he made me realize something.
What's that?
Uh,
since I was born premature,
I was left in an incubator for a long time and apparently I have abandonment
issues stemming from that.
From that,
yeah.
I don't remember it.
But he said that's the worst kind of abandonment issues is,
is being a premature.
No.
Is that,
I don't remember it or oh,
really?
Put me on this trajectory of,
but can anyone remember?
And he also said that,
uh,
my,
propensity to do opioids in my early days might've stunted,
might come forever
not to spoil the episode.
Wait a minute though.
Can I ask you something?
Yeah.
What opioids,
where were you into a percosets you were doing them a lot.
Yeah.
When I had eye surgery I got pretty into those.
And that can ruin the function.
Yeah.
Cause it just a,
you don't have that satisfaction ever again.
Dulls everything.
And what about it has,
it has the real uplifting stuff.
He told me,
made me hopeful.
What about the,
um,
you know,
the goal,
the,
the theory that we were kind of,
oh,
he,
uh,
he did prescribe me weird sex.
He said I have to have as much and more weird sex.
Really?
Yeah.
So that was the best thing I've ever heard from a doctor.
How,
what do you mean?
He's like,
he's like,
that might be the key to this whole,
yeah.
Like stop your standard missionary shit.
Yeah.
He's like,
why waste time with that kind of like,
you know,
vaginal shit.
Right.
Let's get into some,
no,
he didn't say the specifics.
He just said try some weirder shit,
which I'm completely onboard with by the way.
It's got to be plenty of hose out there that are on board with it too.
I mean,
I would hope so.
Coming in.
They're still coming here and there.
You know,
I uh,
I'm putting pins on the map for the make Josh come to her 2020 are we,
are we going to sign?
We're going to set that thing up.
We got stu dude.
I mean the mill road.
Shad.
He's D is getting,
yeah.
Itchy over here and it was written right.
You,
the Melrose show was great.
It was fun.
Thank you for coming.
By the way,
if you came to that,
that was a lot of fun.
Yeah.
We need just to make jobs come to her.
Has the,
the,
the theory that the smoke show,
which is the key to it all,
I think.
Are we leaning into that?
Yeah,
of course.
I mean it couldn't hurt.
Yeah.
You know,
it's not like roll is the remedy.
I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
Like Dr drew definitely didn't say that shit.
Let me ask you a question,
Josh.
When a doctor gives you medicine,
what does he do?
He blank medicine.
He prescribes,
prescribes,
prescribes.
Is that wrong?
What prescribes what?
He said Perce crabs.
You.
He,
he what?
Say it again.
Oh.
Perscribed is this one wrong too?
Yeah,
it's wrong.
What is it?
It was prescribed.
Prescribed.
Yeah.
Yes.
He doesn't turn scribe?
No.
It not prescribed.
Prescribed.
No,
no,
no.
Is that wrong?
Well,
let's element Interi it's not prescribed.
It's elementary school.
That's not that.
Yeah.
It's pretty prescribed.
Prescribed even when it sucks.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
okay,
so now you have to just bang a bunch of slides.
Yeah.
Try some stuff out.
Try.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I'm down for more reps,
more experimentation.
I'm up for it all.
Okay.
So 2020,
I'm coming to your town and hopefully I'm coming in your town.
Elementary.
It is elementary.
Um,
all right,
let's set up this episode.
So this was pretty awesome.
Yeah,
this is Rhett and link.
There's so sweet.
If you guys don't know,
these guys have a youtube channel that they have multiple youtube channels.
Actually.
They like downplayed how many youtube channels.
They were like,
Hey,
we've got a couple and a one of them has 15 million subscribers and other one is
like,
oh,
just like five and a few more.
These are like,
Oh gee,
youtube guys who could not be nicer.
Um,
we've,
I've found out in the,
during this interview that even some of the content that they created,
we actually played on this show as funny content maybe 10 years ago,
very early days cause of like how funny the,
the stuff was there.
Anyway,
they're super funny.
They're super talented,
they're super successful and they are very open and accessible.
And I think it's a fascinating,
like I'm always fascinated by successful people and what they do.
And I love the business of it all and learning and these guys were so open to,
you know,
telling the story of it.
I just thought it was a fascinating talk with you're a great interview.
And I also liked that we kinda got to see a little hidden dynamic between Oh
yeah.
And link.
So if you pay attention guys,
uh,
we got to see a little marital spat and fine.
Let's just say that one of them is a little more ride or die than the other.
Enjoy retinally your mom's house.
We'll be right back.
If you love hardcore porn,
our next guest don't need any of that.
Uh,
uh,
no.
The um,
the founders of Youtube,
Rhett link linker here.
Okay.
Yeah.
Swing.
I know where to go with it.
I like how you guys have built,
I'm okay.
Like endlessly.
I think we all are endlessly fascinated by non traditional,
um,
like explosive careers in entertainment that aren't like,
I'm on a TV show,
right?
I'm in a movie and you guys have built this unbelievable youtube following.
He's still an empire and it's like,
it's,
I mean it's fascinating.
I just want to know,
I mean first of all,
you guys are North Carolinians,
right?
And you know,
born and raised,
I went to school in North Carolina,
Hickory,
North Carolina,
North Carolina is North Carolina gets,
I mean it really is.
Do you want furniture?
Cause we,
we're the furniture capital.
I love some good furniture.
The big chair is,
I don't know if know the picture is not there,
but they used to swing that furniture capital thing around.
Like they would not let you forget it when you were there.
You're like,
this place sucks.
And they're like the furniture capital.
You'll get that.
So have you gotten over furniture since you've left or not me.
I'm addicted
around it but would love it.
I love it man.
Is that Hickory?
This is not hickory.
North Carolina.
A little town called buoys creek.
What is a little town people?
Oh my God.
Thousand people.
When school's not in session.
Campbell University,
another small school.
Where's buoys creek?
Uh,
in between Raleigh and fable.
Okay,
good.
My uh,
one of my good friends is from a Randleman and Randall Randall.
Randall County.
That's towards the mountains too,
right?
Right.
Well random means a out near out towards Raleigh.
It's where,
uh,
what's his name?
The king is from,
uh,
what's the,
petty,
petty.
He's your mind when North Carolina was that Casey said
you guys are from the same place.
Right?
Cause when you grow up together,
since first grade you've been best friends.
Yeah,
I was born and raised there and rep moved there for first grade.
Wow.
That's,
that's when this started.
And this is where this is,
this is a circle.
It's clearly on a decline that you're here,
but I'm saying,
but like you guys,
so you guys were just buds like in school and yeah.
Yeah.
Like you know,
doing the whole biking around town.
Hey listen,
we lived on opposite sides of town,
which wasn't that far.
So it was like,
all right,
we would meet at the cemetery in the middle of our bike routes and then we would
pick a way to go depending on after desecrating some grapes.
You guys have to know some scandalous shit about each other.
Yeah,
they definitely do.
I see.
I knew you were going to rip us apart.
You know where he buried the bodies,
right?
Yeah,
no.
for sure.
No,
we didn't actually desecrate anybody's,
you don't have to desecrate it to bury it.
That's true.
I just want to clarify that.
Well,
we men knows what to do with a dead body.
Jump over a,
a a dead cow that had died in the midst of childbirth.
Oh,
sort of bring it down.
We would frequent a cow pasture.
Yeah.
And just,
I don't know who's who were the farmer was or anything,
but we would go there and we would chase the cows like on foot.
It's a very exhilarating feeling to have cows scatter out in front of you.
I don't know if you know if you've said he's doing no,
I've never even melt a cow.
I mean I grew up in San Fernando Valley.
You should definitely do it regularly.
It's about it really for real.
It feels right
when you're doing it,
you're like,
this is definitely what I should be doing.
It's warm,
it's warm.
It's not pasteurized and homogenized tastes like milk is different.
The score,
it is so small.
It's just,
it.
You can't really get more than a mouthful.
Does it feel wholesome or Kinky?
Cause it kind of,
I don't know,
a little both.
It feels like we're wholesome meats.
Kinky.
Yeah.
Lips on the outer.
That's the,
well I didn't put my lips on it.
It was more of a video for your lips up to it and you're like,
yeah,
I mean as far as video,
you know,
it wasn't like,
oh,
it was for a video.
Like,
so I go to sleep,
man,
I didn't go out to the barn.
If you want to clarify.
Yeah.
When we were chasing cut Cal's,
we weren't doing it in order to then mill.
That was,
he did a different catch as adults.
You guys been friends for forever,
like your entire life basically.
You ever had the kind of fights where you don't talk for like months it can go?
No,
you've never done it.
We fight mean we fight all the time.
Do you?
Oh yeah.
What do you guys fight if you fight about like content or just we definitely,
yeah,
we have,
we have like the way we approach things creatively,
um,
is kind of our strength and weakness in our relationship.
So,
uh,
in that I kind of try to move things forward.
He tries to finish them and so that's kind of,
we've kind of constantly battling with that.
But,
and then we just,
I mean it's more like an old married couple or brothers in that,
just all the things that a normal person might find endearing about link.
I find it annoying if vice versa.
Emphasize the vice versa.
Like get lost.
I mean we also fight about,
I mean I'm the one,
I get my feelings get hurt,
so I'm the feelings get hurt guy.
Well maybe my feelings get hurt and I just,
you know,
I don't show it well the eye.
Oh,
interesting.
But I would just say that's a gracious way of May.
I don't wear my emotions on my sleeve.
You're the asshole who hurts my feelings guy.
Okay,
here's how I'm really,
is what I'm really trying to totally starting to figure out that when he's hurt,
even though he doesn't have to say it.
No.
You know,
when he's hurt,
I think it's that big of a problem.
Yeah.
For a problem to express emotion and yeah.
Therapy.
Yeah.
So are we aggressive?
Go ahead.
Yeah,
I love it.
Yeah.
Because it,
cause I think that being able to,
you first you have to be able to do fee.
Like my therapist asked me things like,
so what do you feel?
And I'm like,
hmm.
Feel.
Yeah.
What is that?
Then what do I feel?
And then he's like,
but where,
where do you feel it?
And I'm like,
this is getting weird.
Yeah.
I feel it right here.
You know?
And so,
yeah.
So I could see how it would be difficult if you were interacting with me to know
that I was having an issue.
Sure.
Without me saying it.
But isn't that a big deal that you're actually kind of addressing it and talking
about,
well,
according to my wife,
it's a really big picture.
She's super stoked about that.
Yeah.
No,
it's good.
It's good.
And I do think it's,
I mean we've talked about,
well you guys understand this.
We,
we've talked about anytime we start thinking about it was something we were
going to do,
a compensation we're going to have even recently talking about,
let's do something where we see a,
um,
like a,
uh,
a couple's therapist.
But for our friendship,
not that there's,
it's falling apart,
but that because we actually said wouldn't this be a great podcast?
Yeah.
Cause you had this tendency to want to monetize every yeah.
Every conversation.
Sure,
sure.
Yeah.
Again,
that was,
that was my idea.
Well that's what I said.
Then you were like,
ah,
no,
I'm not trying to take credit for the idea.
I'm just saying that we ended up deciding it wasn't a good idea.
Well I don't know what it actually is.
I've come out,
it could be a good idea at some point,
but you know,
once,
you know,
I have to kind of have to learn what body part is feeling.
What before?
How'd that kind of,
I don't know.
I don't know if I would know how to answer that.
Like what,
what body parts you need to be in therapy.
Do you have a therapy?
Would you go?
Oh yeah,
it definitely independently.
Yeah.
I don't want to go to the same therapist.
No.
Yeah,
no.
of course.
So I'm not going to do that cause I've already turned him against you.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
I've got to have somebody on my side,
we're going to eat,
we're going to have like,
can you have a therapy battle where you're like,
you bring your three
therapist shut.
You guys have to get out there.
That's a video I would click a few times.
While
you have your thick written right.
Therapists are like your guys a deck.
That was a good idea.
Yeah,
this is good.
I would watch that.
I want,
I want in on this action,
right?
Yeah.
So anyway,
the cow,
I was pregnant
and so,
um,
it was bloated and then the calf had made it halfway out.
I didn't want to not go back to them.
I don't want to hear it.
Oh No.
Terrible.
We went up to it and we just like stood there and looked at it.
He was like,
it's one of the most memorable moments of our childhood.
Yeah.
Oh is that right?
Cause we just like stood there and then there we go.
I'm sorry.
We were like,
we got the feeling I'm a mouth.
When you encounter something like that,
you feel that need to say meaningful things.
Yeah.
So I don't remember.
I don't remember what we said,
but we said some things that were meaningful to 12 year olds or however all we
were.
And then one of us said,
you think we can jump over it?
Such a boy,
little boy.
We started jumping over.
It gets awesome.
Yeah.
Risk.
You know,
if you,
if you can't,
it's,
that's a big mess.
Yeah.
It looked like it was explosive.
It was,
it was ready to go at any moment.
Do you folks still go back to Carolina?
All the families.
They're everywhere.
Everywhere.
Maybe once.
It's almost,
it's just once a year now though.
Like sometimes twice.
Usually just once.
It's kind of blow like a holiday thing at this point.
It is.
Yeah.
And um,
so when you guys,
did you guys,
you went to high school together too in college and college roommates?
What?
Yeah,
Wolf Pack.
Yeah.
Awesome.
I've never lived alone because,
um,
you know,
I moved out of the house into the college dorm with him and then,
uh,
got engaged and married right out of college.
So I moved out of our apartment into holy shit,
like a house with my wife.
So it's like I never had,
I've never experienced that living by myself.
It's great.
I mean,
I didn't either,
weren't only child though.
Oh,
you mean my mom.
She was gone a lot though.
Your mom latchkey kid.
A little bit.
Yeah.
Only child.
Physically a latch.
What is a,
what is
it means you have a key to your own home and then at your school you just let
yourself,
and my mom came in like a cellar
latch.
Latchkey kids are often like that are there prisoners can go.
I could go ahead and come as I pleased.
Yeah.
That's Kinda cool.
Yeah,
it was.
It was.
All right.
Tell me about,
so when you guys graduate,
do you have the aspirations,
the goals of,
of what you do now or not at all?
There was no point of reference for it.
So rewinding a little bit,
in high school
we,
we both had this idea that we wanted to go to film school,
Right.
And so
we kind of just did things in it.
We weren't going to,
we were going to make a decision together.
There's a great one in Carolina,
Carolina School of the arts.
But like we didn't have,
we didn't even know about that.
Like we just didn't,
you know,
is this a different time?
Well,
we were those guys with the video camera,
like doing the school pride shirt and like stuff,
it's kind of like,
when is the Internet?
Sorry,
this was,
we graduated from high school in [inaudible] 96 so this would have,
you know,
early nineties,
97 cents a young guy ever.
Anyways.
And so I told my dad,
I was like,
we're thinking about going to film school.
And he was like,
well,
I'm not going to pay for that Jay,
because he had no point of reference either.
He's all,
our parents were like super supportive this point.
And
my dad would have been a stand up if he wasn't a law professor.
I mean,
he's hit his audience at this point,
but he,
uh,
he was,
he just expected just to do something normal.
So we both were good at math and so,
and some friends were going to NC state.
You could go to NC state,
you do engineering if you're good at math.
So we both got engineering.
What,
what?
And then get that because that's so you left when you graduated,
you went got engineering jobs.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And uh,
I was,
I was a civil engineer.
I designed like a drainage systems for power plants.
I have a degree in philosophy.
What'd you say?
I feel better about your success knowing how smart,
yeah,
it's crazy.
I'll be talking about,
it makes me feel worse.
Like if four years of calculus,
but you know what I need to make?
How many have engineers,
engineers out there want a murder you,
they're like,
I studied all this shit and here I am fucking figuring out Janet sisterly doing
it.
These two dicks make video.
They're so upset.
I don't even know what calculus is.
Not Serious.
I'm not kidding.
I got to,
I moved my freshman year of high school,
we moved down to Florida,
Vero beach,
and I went to,
they threw me into whatever it was,
Algebra one failed like f,
f,
F,
this is,
you're the worst student.
Then they next year I took geometry and I actually got a B and I was like,
maybe I'm good at math.
Yeah.
And then junior year they're like,
well you failed Algebra one,
you got to take it again.
I took Algebra one twice as well and I was failing straight up and we're in the
math teacher was also an assistant football coach and was like,
I'll give you a D,
I'll hook you up with a d.
And then a freshman year in college,
they had like a Rameet,
like the other gift,
you take one math class for this track.
I failed it.
And then senior year of college,
they're like,
the only way you can graduate college from Lenore Ryan is to take that remedial
math class again.
So I was a senior with all freshmen.
Oh Wow.
And the guy was like,
you're so bad.
You're the worst student I've ever had.
And I saw he had a magazine about boats on his desk.
I was like,
I'm going boats.
And he was like,
Oh really?
And I started talking about,
I made a boat connection.
I started reading about boats,
talking about bows.
He gave me a c
but I would stay after class and be like,
you see that new a 20 foot super that came out,
like just talk to him about.
But he was like,
yeah.
Was pretty cool.
Just connected on that.
And that's,
you're not talking about like sail boats area,
just motor.
But yeah,
you can not like,
what do they call the inboard and like motorboats but that's a good life skill.
Like that's the kind of stuff I want to teach our children.
Be Dumb but not at a talk.
That's what's sad.
Yeah.
Because that's all that's better in life.
Right.
That's shit that you're going to fill skill.
Yeah.
That,
and I encourage little bit of lying.
You should lie in your teen years as well to your parents.
I'm going to a movie when you're really making out with your boyfriend,
right?
That kind of,
you gotta lie to your boss.
Yes.
A little things.
Not Big things.
It's not to the IRS and stuff like that,
but a little,
you know.
Yeah,
sure.
No,
it's true.
There's a lot of loopholes and what you did kind of manipulated to your teacher.
No,
I totally,
yeah,
cause also because I had no out cause I was like,
I've,
I don't do this.
Look good.
I'm going to not graduate.
And now you do.
You know about boats.
That's true.
Well true.
A very important skill.
More than that.
You were like hanging out on the weekends on that dude on the phone and we're
like going kneeboarding or that's right.
No know.
Oh that dude he was,
he was Kinda of weird.
He was,
did you guys sleep in the same bed as you show your bed?
I had all kinds of teachers that just liked me.
Yeah.
Like they genuinely liked me and only in the subjects that I was horrible in
chemistry,
the guy,
I was like,
God,
do you really not get this?
But you're nice and yeah,
that's what he was just like into it.
Yeah.
You are attractive.
He was like,
you are pretty cute though.
Yeah.
How about a mouth?
Can I kissed him
before I forget.
You guys and I,
we're
both a date were a day apart.
We're doing the Nashville comedy festival.
Yeah,
that's right.
You guys are April 9th.
I'm April 10th.
We're both at the Ryman and there are no tickets available.
Oh,
you fucked up.
Have you done anything in the Ryman?
We've have not.
I've never,
I've never done it.
I heard it's a beautiful space and uh,
people,
a lot of friends who have done,
uh,
played there and they said it's like an awesome,
awesome venue.
And what do you guys do in your live show,
by the way?
It's a comedy music.
Oh,
okay.
Two stools,
a guitar,
lots of songs.
I mean,
that's the first thing we did on youtube where we put the funny songs that we've
written over the previous years.
When you're doing this,
like putting those on youtube,
you're,
that it existed,
but your engine,
you're working as engineers during the day.
Yeah,
we would get together like once a week,
um,
one night,
a week and light right together.
And then we were,
we were in college,
we would,
you know,
yeah,
we did the video thing,
but then we also did the,
hey,
we wrote a funny song,
guys,
let it sit on the couch.
We're going to play a four year kind of thing.
So it's like,
it's a hobby.
It's like,
oh,
this is fun.
Right?
Yeah.
And then,
and so we started doing some like a small college stuff and like performing.
Yeah.
Okay.
And so then we created our website.
This is like oh three so we were like,
oh,
we need to create,
create a website so that we may choose like,
oh five right?
Am I wrong?
Yeah.
And we got to know six is like very few people got into a fight.
That's when it like started
like in the summer oh five.
But we were,
we like,
we're putting these music videos on our website.
So people who saw us live could see the videos.
But then people started taking like,
so we did that for a couple of years and not really going anywhere.
And then people started taking those videos and download from the website
because it was back in the day,
he had to like host your own video,
like using server.
People had quick time pro,
they could just right click on the video,
upload it to them,
and they were taking it,
downloading it,
and then uploading it to youtube.
And we were at,
is that helping in a way because it's sharing it,
right?
Yeah.
Because hundreds of people had seen our videos on our website and then somebody
uploaded a,
we did this.
Our,
our kids were really young.
Like my son was a couple months old probably.
And,
and,
and his daughter was like a year we did a parody of MPVs pimp,
my ride penalize stroller basically completely tricked out this stroller.
And somebody took that and upload it to youtube and it got like a thousand views
in a week or something.
And you guys were like,
Whoa,
whoa,
this is crazy.
That's way bigger than any plates we've ever relayed.
Um,
and so we started doing it intentionally,
you know,
six and then in oh seven,
we started it as a business.
Wow.
Is that when you realize,
is that when you stop working engineering jobs?
Yeah.
So,
oh seven you're ready to,
to like make the leap?
Yeah,
we,
yeah.
I can't remember the first with the first paying Gig was,
but we essentially started making,
we were,
this is before you can make money off of Youtube,
but the ads,
because when it started there were no ads
and before Google bought it and everything.
So what we would do is we would make phone calls,
but we wrote a song about the game corn hole in the Midwest,
you know?
No,
of course.
So we wrote like this sort of country song about corn hole and uh,
we were like surely some corn hole company out there with spots or this thing.
So we,
like we would call,
we would go on a website that sold corn hole equipment and like call the number.
And like one was like this mom who was like running the business out of her
garage.
And she was like,
I just don't have any money.
And then we liked,
but then we were like,
really?
You still Cornell equipment on the Internet?
But we found these other guys,
these other guys who are like three guys about our age who are starting this new
business and like Ohio and they were really excited about it.
They love the idea of like doing some kind of like viral marketing.
And so like we,
with the help of my dad,
I like wrote up this contract.
We had no idea.
Like we were like,
maybe we should just say we get paid.
I think what we said was we're like,
we want $2,000 to make the video.
And then if you could give us $20 for every thousand views after that.
Yeah.
For two years.
And the thing and were getting like two or 3 million views,
we hadn't,
you know,
we had no idea what we were sued them right.
As Troy their lives.
Like,
you've signed that fucking shit.
I mean,
they paid us,
they paid us.
They did.
Wow.
I'm assuming it,
it also benefited them in a great,
oh yeah.
They were like,
they made corn hole.
We ended up doing it.
[inaudible] JJ cornhole.
They're still paying.
If we did a,
which camera do I look at?
That website?
Ignorant.
I dunno what corn haul.
I mean,
I know what corn hole and right
you,
but you've seen the game with the big,
it's like a Tilton board and you throw the beanbag.
Oh yeah.
Haha.
Another name for it.
Okay.
All right.
I think it was a real,
oh,
ogs.
I think beanbag tosses botox.
It's not a,
it's got corn in the bag.
Yeah,
and that gives it that,
that righteous,
right.
It's the board.
It makes you want to take another swig of your beer because it isn't what we
believed at the time to be the next Olympic sport and the only one where you
could drink beer because we didn't know about the Shimmy Shimmy game.
What's that?
Oh yeah.
Full board shuffleboard.
No,
the Olympic,
no,
the curling.
Curling.
Yeah.
I think you can drink a beer while doing that too.
Oh,
for sure.
When you make that corn whole video and it starts to take off or you like a
word,
this is it that we did the right,
like this is what we should be doing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean like we started doing,
we started doing that with other,
other products we would just call and you just randomly just cold call people.
Yeah.
And now you have some reference and be like,
check these out.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Uh,
and then in Oh eight,
uh,
this advertising advertising agency called and they wanted to his Alka Seltzer,
they represented Alka Seltzer and they wanted us to do like a bunch of food
theme videos.
And they had,
originally they had talked to the Sklar brothers about doing this and um,
I think they probably,
they were probably smart enough to like charge money for it.
Um,
we were desperate and we were like,
but it ended up,
I mean it was a l w I don't,
again,
I don't remember what the price was,
but it was not a lot to make 21 videos over the course of the summer.
And they were going to like take us in this RV around the u s and we were gonna
like show up at a place and create something.
Yeah.
Um,
and so
I remember the first day of the guys under Cusick Lars.
Yeah.
Well we met him after that and that they didn't seem to care,
but they didn't get that job.
They were cool with it.
Yeah.
Uh,
but I remember that,
or the
first day when we showed up on location and they're like,
all right,
here's your RV.
And I'm like,
Damn,
they got a nice RV.
Right?
And it's like the whole team is lined up out there and there's like Canadian
writers that they flew in and it was probably eight or nine people lined up and
they're like,
all right,
here's the RV.
And we're like,
okay,
let's go.
And we start getting on the RV and we turn around and they're like standing
there and we're like,
okay,
we're ready.
And they're like,
yeah,
go.
And they had just given us the RV and then they all got in like a passenger van
and followed us around the country.
Really.
And we've felt horrible.
I mean,
now I'd be like,
yeah,
he can't get it.
My RFP,
that was like naive and you know all the money that they didn't spend on us,
they spend on like that's awesome.
And Coors light,
they kept giving us cores.
Like you can't drink Coors light to this day because it just,
when you're in the back of an RSV Harvey no good.
Like they would open the door to the RV and we wouldn't know where we were.
I mean,
we didn't drink that much quarter's light,
but I mean,
you'd get disoriented.
It's kind of like probably like just,
you know,
traveling,
doing your gigs or whatever.
At some point you're like,
I don't exactly know where I'm at.
Yeah.
They'd open the door and be like,
well,
uh,
we're in Maine.
You got six hours and make a video God.
And then they would shut the door and they'd open it again.
This is what it feels like now in retrospect was like we were in somewhere in
the Midwest and I was like,
you're at a board game convention.
We've got,
you asked to go in there and make a video.
It was like a,
like a role playing role playing games.
So would you guys just brainstorm the whole way to the next place and come on
with something?
We would like,
we would work something out like for that it was,
we're going to go and they've given us like a space on the floor and we're going
to say that we've got a new role playing game and that we need the test
audience.
And so it was called intergalactic food smugglers.
Yeah.
Cause it had to be about food because of Alka Seltzer.
Oh,
right.
It makes sense.
At a certain point you've got to start popping those Alka Seltzer.
Since then,
have you done a lot of food?
You know,
like,
yeah.
No it wasn't because that was oh eight and then we didn't start GMM.
Good mythical morning until 2012 and we didn't start eating stuff on GMM until a
couple of years until 2014 to give people who don't know that are listening or
watching.
Uh,
how many youtube channels do you guys have?
I've Damn fiveish five ish.
He's kind of our loose,
I mean we've got good mythical morning is a show and then every morning,
yeah that show continues.
So there's like 10 more minutes that's good.
Mythical more where it's like more laid back like behind the scenes another
channel but hanging out more of the same show.
And then we have our podcasts,
ear biscuits that we do every week and that's another channel.
And that's basically we have the [inaudible] have our main charity,
original
Rhett and link channels.
What I'm saying,
which we like,
it's basically just an archive at this point because we don't have a,
we're not uploading anything to it just because you're focusing on the other
places.
Yeah cause everything,
any whatever we're doing that's like narrative scripted stuff that we're
developing is more traditional route right now.
So instead of trying to do that on youtube.
Oh going traditional as in TV.
Yeah.
Yoga.
So I mean we did,
we had like a youtube red I guess youtube premium now show like a half hour
comedy for two seasons on that.
But again,
that was we,
we,
and I think we put that on the GMM channel because it has this point that
channel has like 15 million subscribers versus being the original channels got
like four or five bullshit.
Yeah.
Because it's just the,
because the daily,
the GMM was just a,
a side project.
So the reason we moved to La is so if you fast forward from those Alka Seltzer
days,
you get to,
we just started like we were making our money through just brand integrations.
Right.
Then eventually we turned off like we got into the youtube partner programs
where they caught it at the time where,
you know,
the ad sends money started coming in.
So we kind of supplemented our income doing that.
Yes.
So they share like 55% with the creators.
It's like a standard.
Right.
And,
but we are continuing to do that.
Uh,
and then we were trying all kinds of stuff.
This is all back in North Carolina like we would,
we music videos,
sketch.
Um,
and then one of the things that's really started hitting and like,
oh eight oh nine was we started making local commercials.
Yes.
I've seen a few of them.
We did,
we did one for a furniture place.
No Red House furniture,
wherever the white people and white people
love that one.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think years ago we just audio only we played that on their show.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We're in the ad,
you know,
singing that part.
Oh my gosh.
That's you guys.
Yeah.
So we started doing that.
Right.
Black people,
white people is still allowed to buy furniture there only block,
no,
no.
All people or as the guy at the end of the things as an Hispanic people to
expand it.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
but we,
so we did that and then that was like the first time we started getting interest
from La.
We,
all these production companies started calling and saying,
we'd love to turn this into some kind of show.
Um,
we ended up selling a season of the show to IFC.
That was when we packed everybody up and move to the loss.
So that show was only one season,
but we made,
we made one commercial for a taxidermist in Ohi called Chuck Testa.
So there was like a meme that was,
nope,
chuck Testa.
Was that,
is that like doing that?
That was that also just off a cold call.
Do you just,
well I'll place at that.
No,
at that point,
you know,
through the production company they said,
all right,
we're going to do the casting.
Thanks.
So then people would send in tapes.
Oh,
I got you.
So there was like a once,
it was like an audition tape where it was like Chuck's son was filming him skin
something and to dude's barefoot.
And he talks like this and he's very deadpan and we're like,
this guy's great.
So we came up with,
nope,
chuck Testa,
like just watching the audition tape and we're like,
I bet you we can talk this guy into doing anything.
And it was like a really good sport.
Any like,
he says it like,
it changed my life for maybe a year.
I don't know.
He's,
he's still a friend of
you.
Do you,
uh,
you guys had or have you done or are interested in doing features at all or no?
Yeah,
I mean,
we,
10 years ago,
well,
more than 10 years ago now,
we,
we did it like a documentary feature that was us trying to find our first grade
teacher.
Oh,
I saw that.
Spoiler alert.
Founder.
Yeah.
Look at you and miss lot.
You're watched it or you saw that it existed.
I saw that it exists,
but
what'd you still going to spoil it?
I know you said on your video
set it and we read it is yeah.
But yeah,
no,
we want it.
We don't have nothing in the works right now.
Uh Huh.
Uh,
but yeah.
Are you ever like,
do you ever stop?
Like,
are you ever astounded at like that?
Not like 15 million.
It's crazy.
It's crazy,
right?
Because when we started touring and like the,
you know,
like the Gig at the Ryman,
I mean,
just to be able to say,
oh,
we're playing at the Ryman,
less wild country music fans.
That's,
that's pretty amazing.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
we get went to Australia and like people are buying tickets and showing up.
It's just weird man.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
And again,
like I think it's even like,
you know,
we come from standup so you think of it like it's a,
more traditional path.
Right.
But like you basically built this path like there that didn't really exist for
you.
Yeah,
we are.
We've just kind of stumbled into the next thing.
Twilio,
it's,
it's we an hour at this place where,
because of the popularity of this one show we can show,
we wouldn't have to necessarily be funny.
Like we would still probably have people show up,
which I think is probably happening with youtubers who are doing live shows.
I'm not going to name any names,
but I the,
we have this,
this way that we can have an idea.
Like we just were finishing a novel right now that's coming out in the fall that
is,
uh,
you know,
it's all it kind of based in,
and the two boys who are freshmen in high school kind of encountering some weird
stuff in their town.
And the fact that people,
we've got a built in audience who's going to read that hopefully beyond the
audience will read it as well.
Sure.
But it just gives you the A,
you can kind of play around with Tabatha Presale,
manic.
I got an order order that thing.
Do you mean,
so look,
since you guys are such,
um,
you know,
uh,
so into and knows the youtube audience so well and how it works.
I mean,
can you give us some guidance?
Like we have a Fart Mike,
right?
So anybody doing to up our game one?
Anything?
Any advice?
Hmm.
Well,
let me see what you got.
Hit me on the Fart,
Mike.
Yeah,
I have nothing right now.
Empty.
Do you guys have any farts?
Uh,
no.
I just thought maybe I did,
but I was,
I really wanted to think about it for you.
Yeah.
Glad you did.
Well,
he has,
you have farted on you farted on firearms on the podcast one time.
Right into the mic though.
So we each fund and Mike was here,
but I mean it was hard.
Gmn You'd hear it.
Oh,
GMM.
We've each farted,
uh,
unintentionally and it was caught on camera and left.
We found that quite funny.
Hey,
do we have that clip of their food?
The thing,
let me load it up.
Yeah.
The,
there's um,
just to kind of inform the audience,
like here's a,
yeah,
you guys,
I felt like I disappointed you cause I didn't fart.
And Dear Mike,
I'll let you know if one comes out.
Here's a written link food tasting video that we found.
2010.
This is when you had a beard.
Look at that belly
cause I'm a fucking glutton done.
Low Angle is great
baby.
It's fucking man and
people legs.
Oh
No,
never seen this guy.
It's fucking lag off its first fucking leg.
Well he'd switched up so he,
that's king ass ripper.
And uh,
he used to just exclusively do fart videos under the handle.
I fart in your face and he would get kicked off of youtube and he'd go to live
leak and then lively could get kicked off.
We're were torn and tattered.
Well No,
there was a little seeks.
So he would look kind of at,
you'd see a color change and he would do things like
they were really like,
they looked worse than that shirt that's on,
you know what I mean?
He's a guy where did and he would just like walk up the stairs,
turn around,
look at you fart.
Or I'd lay on the couch two thumbs up.
But see I don't mean to,
but he went down the glutton angle now.
So now he's all about,
and
personally I like his earlier work.
I'm in the car.
It's a little more on your payroll cause I'm about to,
I go a new one.
No,
no,
no.
Please ask for a new one.
I don't like this guy because he's,
you know,
please tell us he could be real,
but he's not like the Internet's the Internet can,
it can contain the real version of it.
You don't like the bit,
I think this is a bit virgin.
There was a,
I mean there's a guy who was on Instagram who was a,
he was a security guard.
It's like,
that guy's great.
Yeah,
that's an artist.
It's a good work.
He,
I mean,
he got fired for fun.
you've talked to him.
No,
we,
no.
Yeah,
he's bringing him out.
It's just like that about this guy.
The Kang here.
He won't,
he won't respond.
We've tried calling him dedicated to video Tufts once dedicated to your mom's
house,
but
he,
he won't actually,
he scared dairy co coy.
No,
wait,
so what you're saying,
I'm saying he's not a good character.
I'm just saying once you seen the real thing,
you know,
they,
that kind of exist and this is just frustrates you knowing that you're not
seeing it.
You're saying that you don't feel the authenticity from this guy.
He feel like this is a show and this is not who he is.
Is that what you're telling me?
Wow.
I've never see.
You want it to read more genuine or grounded grounded performance at this is,
this is a performance he's playing.
A character will see that.
I think that like my favorite thing about,
there's nothing wrong with that.
No,
I get it.
But just when you've seen the real thing,
the commercials you made,
you know,
those like the great thing about those commercials,
I mean it's I guess a subjective,
depends on your sense of humor was when you feel like this is real,
you know what I mean?
Like Dad,
you know,
the first one we ever made,
we made it for furniture,
another furniture place,
Bobby Denny furniture in somewhere in North Carolina.
High point and a high points real close.
No,
no,
not hide.
It wasn't high point though.
It was free.
It was down in Mount Olive Anyway,
but we made the commercial for them and they had this like tradition and making
really,
you know,
funny commercials,
unintentionally funny commercials.
Uh,
and we acted like we were two of the family members and we kind of like where
the leads and the commercial and we got that to be a part of it.
But we watched it back.
We were like,
well,
we put it out.
We did it.
I was like,
this is not great.
Uh,
but at the same time we made the red house and then the Cuban gynocologist
because that guy,
that guy was in high point.
So that's the guy who was a used car salesman from Cuba who had been a
gynocologist Cuba.
And so we kind of leaned into that and it was like,
I didn't give him a stethoscope.
He had it in his drawer sales desk and that's why I was in,
and that's the switch we made was we don't,
why,
why do we have to play characters with these real people?
Basically writing this for us.
I mean,
that's what we like.
We've always found the stuff that we make that we're not in to be,
that's our favorite stuff is stuff that,
and when it's real,
it's like,
is this is based on this guy's story is one of those commercials maybe as the
furniture one or maybe it's another one where you had the mother,
somebody who was like,
try to say a line like 40 times.
Um,
we got scooters.
Yeah.
Was it?
We got scooters that was,
that was an outtake from the one that he's talking about where we played the two
brothers.
Yes.
And then we realized that was so much funny.
That was hilarious.
That's when it clicked it.
And she's scooters.
She could like,
she would even like screw up.
We got scooters,
right.
There's 10 different ways.
And she frustrated or,
so we got her to market.
We said you can market a scooter to people who've had DUIs.
So we're like,
oh,
that's right.
You got a Dwi,
get a scooter.
And she couldn't say Dwi.
Right.
That's what it was.
That was,
that was yours.
Yeah.
That should've been the ad.
Right.
That was just an outfit.
That's it.
That should be your only
thing that got DWI.
He scooter.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Um,
so you guys were,
one of the things we discussed sometimes on this show is,
you know,
we're married.
You guys are basically a married couple,
by the way.
Very good looking guys.
I can see why you have a successful channel.
So God,
they're good looking.
They are.
There is so much cuter than youtubers are generally cuter than comedians.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
You guys have a look.
I can see why.
You know,
the more we spend a lot of time on her hair.
Yeah.
He has great hair.
You get outfits,
you're very fit.
That's when I can tell you guys when Hollywood with that hair.
But anyway.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
That's not North Carolina hair.
Right.
So anyway,
we discussed with,
yeah,
you're nice.
Chanel's we discussed whether or not you know how ride or die.
Um,
one of the scenarios that came up once was like,
I go to Starbucks,
it's like an addiction every day.
And I have a very specific order.
It's not that complicated,
but I like a splash of milk.
A lot of times I'll watch them just dump milk,
like get upset.
And I told her,
you know what,
if I were to wait outside one of these locations and I target the Barista who
made it wrong,
I killed them in a fit of rage.
And then I come home and I'm like,
I gotta tell you something.
I killed somebody today.
Oh,
okay.
Would you turn me in?
So let's flip the scenario and mean you guys,
your partner here is like,
hey man,
I know we're about to record.
Uh,
I gotta tell you something real quick.
I know we're going to try out these hot dogs,
but let me tell you something real quick.
Ah,
ah,
I kill somebody today.
Anyways,
you got to understand I'm not good with hypothetical situations.
So when you pitch a hypothetical,
I start to internalize it as real.
So like I'm an emotional guy.
I feel like you're going to fucking break here.
Yeah,
that's fine.
I think this is a pretty clear thing.
Yeah.
I would have my answer.
I would try to find a way to help him evade the situation.
This is my man was sitting,
by the way,
it turned me in and
you and I have a similar conversation with our therapist.
My therapist is also like,
you are living in a narrow bandwidth of emotions
and then she's like,
call immediately.
Immediately.
Yeah.
Well,
here's my thinking.
Okay.
Because he's the father of my small children and if here's,
here's the deal,
man,
if it were alike,
he kills a pedophile or he kills a somebody that hurts our family.
Dude,
on the first one to get a shovel,
I'm going to help him get rid of the body.
Right?
Okay.
Now,
if it's just a Barista at Starbucks who gets his drink order over and over
wrong,
it means that something's wrong,
right?
Something screw screwy up here,
Who knows what's he's going to snap on next.
That's not a reason to kill a man or a woman said to me,
I tell her this one time,
she's like,
oh,
what if you're going to kill me in the kids?
Yes.
Take it slow because he's capable,
but why?
Why wouldn't I take it
there?
He is capable of murdering a Barista over an incorrect drink order.
Who would say he's not going to turn that rage on myself where the children,
I got to protect my kids.
Do you do stuff for him like splashing milk and the things for them all the time
just to prevent the range?
Yeah.
That's no way to live
nervously splashing milk.
This does.
Oh I do.
I do think he gets in the car.
You're running out later.
See you and I are similar emotionally when I have to
get his Starbucks order.
There is that anxiety and be like I better get this right.
I this right.
Take a measuring spoon.
Oh you know some people bring their own cups mugs and bring your own little
thing and be like this is what you need to put the milk.
You know what I've started to do?
Great idea.
It feels like a,
would you please validate this idea?
No,
no.
I said quite started to address it.
I started to say a black nothing in it and then like when their start making
that I go,
oh,
can I get on the side a little bit of milk that's smart.
And then there'll be like,
do you want room?
And I go,
no,
no.
Cause I don't want them to be like,
well here we'll leave this much.
They just,
what drinking?
What's your drink?
So easy.
Okay.
It is.
It's of this event,
a large iced coffee,
extra ice.
Okay.
No sweetener.
All sweetener.
That's it.
That's how it does.
And then you say,
and then I go,
can I get a side Cup before that?
Before I did that,
yeah.
I would say a splash.
A whole milk.
You say a splash and I would watch these dudes and ladies just go like do two,
two,
two sides.
I'm like,
come on man.
Splashes section.
Not as precise term.
And he's an engineer.
It is a precise term.
But then I would say I would start when I would get frustrated about that,
I would say,
can I get a very small splash?
We're a very small amount.
Yeah.
I would still get like just half a glass of milk.
So then I used to go nigga black.
Got It.
But it's in precise and the engineers these to the brains here are like,
you're being in precise,
but you would help him,
Barry,
you would help him bury the body.
No,
no.
Let's revisit hearing my argument.
Go ahead.
He's a sociopath.
Clearly he's a psychopath.
So you're seeing Rhett did what you,
he has a Barista.
I'm saying in that scenario,
but,
but ret also see if you did something,
just like if she came to me,
if she was at came to me and she was like,
oh,
dropping off the kids at school.
That's a mailman man.
I killed him.
I'd be like,
Oh really?
Let's figure out how to get like hide this and I'm going to help you get out of
this session.
That would be my first thought.
How do I help you get away with,
yeah,
I can provoke.
That would be,
I think my first thought would be unprovoked murder.
Did you hear that?
We both go to prison.
Who's raising the kids?
That's another true.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well first thought we got to get away with it.
I think my thought would be,
I bet.
I bet we don't have to tell anybody.
I bet we can.
Yeah.
Oh,
bullshit.
I think that would,
but then there'd be a second thought right after it.
Like immediately right after it.
It's like there's no way that I can succeed.
I'm pretty good at keeping secrets,
but I'm not good at like a body.
You would be like,
this is what I think.
I think you'd be like,
all right man,
we're definitely,
we're just not going to say anything.
And then he would go to lunch and come back.
He'd be like,
FBI has come.
Yeah.
Cave in a minute.
I feel like he doesn't have the constitution.
You said you feel your emotions,
right?
You Express when your feelings are hurt.
It would be overwhelming.
Yes.
It's a natural thing to do.
Well,
I didn't know the Barista.
I don't know.
My feelings will be hurt.
Well,
maybe you'd be like,
God,
how often are you doing?
I said,
well,
here's the,
here's the mitigating factor,
uh,
that I,
I think you're right that I would just say,
hey,
you're going down man,
and I'm not going with you.
Uh,
because is there a closet in our,
in our insurance,
like we've got probably at a certain point we got,
we got insurance.
Yeah.
Can we talk about it?
Is talking about the insurance make it where if you kill somebody,
I can't get it.
Does it,
does it include like moral failure?
Probably morality,
moral failure.
We need checking it out and if you're morally disabled,
oh wow,
that's a great way to say you're in prison then I am going,
I gotta get,
I gotta get that income that is gone by you not being there,
which is going to be low,
like 95%.
You're going to be like that 5% contribution that you make.
You know,
I want to get that.
I want to get that quantified.
I think if you put this in,
because I,
I,
I think what I would be trying to do is,
I think,
by the way,
I think I'm much more likely to kill somebody,
but I would accidentally,
it will be an accident.
We don't allow him to touch arts sharp objects on the show because he's,
you know,
is a danger to self and others.
I'm impulsive.
I don't think I'm,
but I'm clumsy and I'm impulsive.
Minimizing the damage though because um,
if it a more realistic situation,
like a,
like a hit and run or something,
something like that.
Like,
you know,
I was,
I don't think you should make this more real.
No,
I only hypothetical cause I was watching
is incriminating.
If it's like I was watching,
um,
I guess probably some reddit thread and there was this,
uh,
hidden camera or like surveillance footage of somebody pulling out in front of
this car and the car swerves and the guy like flips and hits assigned.
Turns out the guy that I ended up in critical condition,
the person who caused him to do this just like quickly turns around and goes
away right now.
I,
first of all,
I don't think I would do that cause it's like you're always going to get in
those situations.
Right?
It's e n n I think it'd be too much to deal with if you did get away with it,
but if you made the mistake,
is that what?
No,
I've seen it.
So if you made that mistake,
yeah.
You came home and you tell me,
he's like,
dude,
I just,
okay,
I just caused this guy to rec and then,
but you know,
my car wasn't hit and I'm here now and I think you've got hurt.
What,
what should I do?
I panicked.
I didn't intentionally flea.
I just,
okay.
I fled in a panic.
I think in that situation,
my goal would be to minimize the repercussions in your life.
Right.
And so I think in that situation,
I'd be like,
you gotta go,
you gotta turn yourself in right now,
because that's the most logical thing to do to maximize the situation.
Right?
Yeah.
But if it was a little bit different and it was like
you could get away with this,
I would be the one that would be most likely to find that way and to,
and to help you.
And he's like,
okay.
He's like,
I was in Boone,
I was on a hike and I just didn't like the way I guy looked at me.
I cut them up.
He's like,
come on man,
help me out.
You're like,
all right,
here's what we got to cut him off.
He'll be,
your friend is crazy.
Like he hears me a just a slip up slip up where you chop up a man.
No,
you'd have to think that somebody,
something snapped and drained them.
There's no look at him laughing just like you.
You guys are the Sickos together.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But somethings does.
Yeah.
Something's wrong.
Can you be like this guys?
Lots of shit right now.
He's,
what if he's,
what if he said,
all I need you to do is say that we were having lunch in Peoria.
Can you swing that for me?
I mean,
I,
I'm actually,
I would,
I'm a little scared at how good I would be at doing it.
Same with him.
Yeah.
You guys are kind of looking forward to that call.
I mean,
I always laugh.
People like us,
man,
when I get to make the world go round.
Yeah.
I always look guilty when I didn't do something right.
But I like to think that when I am guilty,
I'm pretty cool about it.
Like,
I don't know.
I,
it's like I have this like investment diversion mentality that it's like I ain't
guilty about everything.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
This is my guilty voice.
I think we have a
great scenario for a feature or an animated show.
You,
you know,
an animated murder cover up.
That's what he carving them out.
Yes.
Dude.
Yeah.
I mean this,
it feels like this is had to have been done.
Right.
What,
what was the feeling it would make it a pet.
What's the movie where he's the,
the,
the uh,
the product that's worse in some ways.
Yes.
The prostitute dies in the very beginning.
Christian Slater was just later.
Oh,
the best movie ever.
American psycho.
No,
no,
I'm sorry.
No,
it's a bad,
it's called like bad day or bad.
I don't know.
It's a very bad thing.
Very bad people or something like that.
What's up bitch?
Sorry.
Texture.
What was your last week he gave us this bitch button to shore.
It was,
I'm about dead prostitutes.
Gotcha.
Yeah,
I was right there,
man.
I thought you were doing that for you.
That's pretty awesome.
I thought you were doing that thing,
which as a seasoned podcast host,
you're like,
we're having that conversation where we're all trying to remember the name of a
movie that everybody knows.
Oh,
right.
When a bitch to this moment.
No,
no,
no.
I wish it were very bad thing.
Sorry about that.
I know you said that.
That's like a group of friends trying to cover as well.
Let me ask you this,
but you can go there again.
We have,
uh,
the segment,
we do call it a horrible,
are hilarious a lot.
We show a video and we just get your reaction to this is funny or is it
terrible?
One of them actually is a incredibly interesting because of the fact that
there's like his two buddies involved in something.
And I'm wondering if you guys would be the hardcore support and friend that the
one person needs.
Okay.
So this is out in,
uh,
the,
why nature right out in as a stream of water,
I guess you would call it.
Um,
and these guys are,
I think they're actually out there trying to,
uh,
get,
what is it?
Fish?
Yeah.
This is a great
lobsters.
Crabs to know that nature.
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
So they're,
they're crabbing there.
Crabbing
guest,
but it does,
it's,
it's not,
uh,
I don't know.
It's not,
it doesn't,
I always thought of crabbing as like the throwing in
the traps.
Yeah.
These guys are like out there with their hands.
This shit.
So are they noodling?
Oh No,
this isn't another part of the kind of noodling.
Okay.
Here we go.
[inaudible]
so he's got it.
He's got a crab on his ding.
Ding.
But then,
okay.
Okay.
Look,
Rhett comes over,
handles it first bra.
Oh,
well sure.
It's still there.
Yeah.
Anyways,
you guys seem deeply troubled.
I am so suspicious of this.
Does it feel contrived?
Yes.
You got a third person with the camera,
right?
You all right.
So what was it?
I was in Bora Bora and I was like,
Hey,
you guys,
did you hook your friend up like that?
Oh God,
the crab on a misdemeanor.
Oh,
why didn't he use his own hands?
That's what I would want.
But that's the main thing.
You got to lands.
They're right there next to the crotch scream and like,
yeah,
he's freaked out.
Right.
So freaked out.
Yeah,
but it's,
this is where the video starts.
It's already,
it's already at this point.
Yeah.
Oh,
right.
He's a good screamer.
Yeah.
He knows that to scream and the,
and the double screen and the other ones.
The other ones.
Yeah.
But if that did it authentically happen to you?
No problem,
man.
No,
you weren't.
Yeah.
I don't think I've ever taken anything off of your penis before,
but when he faces the camera.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Like,
well,
hold on.
Crab.
And he's like,
here,
look at it.
When I moved out.
Oh,
you,
you had that other roommate who moved in and I thought,
I heard the story that you removed a tick from the
Glens of his penis.
Wow.
Whoa.
This is an exclusive,
I feel like I would remind me which exclusive I'm talking about.
Josh says Oyen h x solution.
Sorry.
Hold on.
Is that your voice?
I don't think I removed it,
but I do think that he let you watch.
No,
I think he came,
I think he came home from like a camping trip or something and it was when I was
so after link moved out,
um,
and got married,
I,
I had actually bought this really shady apartment in Raleigh
and then got like six roommates.
I slept on the floor and charge them all rent.
Whoa.
So I just had a distant Lotta guys is coming in and out of there.
As long as they were willing to pay like $200 a month for some portion of a room
they could stay.
Sounds disgusting.
And uh,
there was a guy who when you hear about this guy,
he came home from something and yeah,
he had a,
I think he had a tick on his nuts.
Hmm.
I distinctly remember it being on the wiener on that,
on the tip.
Hmm.
That's how I remember it.
Like tick,
tick,
tick.
I've never heard of a tip tech.
I've never heard of that either.
And they get mad.
I feel like I must have blocked this out cause I definitely did.
I don't remember.
I do have this vague recollection of him showing everyone.
He showed it to,
everyone showed everybody and then he's like,
can you help me out?
And then I think I was like,
my two hands are holding.
Yeah,
definitely.
I would remember if I helped him.
I didn't.
I think he showed it to us and then he went to the bathroom and took care of it
himself.
Jeez.
How do you take care of that?
You just light a flame to it.
How do you do that?
Yeah.
Don't have to burn off the tick or whatever.
Burn the tick after you remove it from your,
from your Pecker,
you burn it onto you.
What you gotta do is you've got to get the pincers out.
So like with tweezers,
you've got to get in there and get it and this is small enough you can paint
nail Polish over a tick and it will,
it will begin to suffocate years,
man.
It,
it'll let loose on the sugars.
You paint red bugs.
Would you,
did you ever get chiggers now?
So they definitely are not out here.
No,
they're in the Midwest,
but they're all over the southeast and you for some reason only get them when
your kids,
but you'll go out and play and then you come back and then you'll have these red
bumps all in your crotch,
like on the upper thighs.
And then your mom takes a nail Polish remover
are clear.
No clear nail Polish and paint over them and it and it,
cause they have like a little breathing tube that they've stuck out of your skin
and they suffocate and die and go away.
Oh my God,
that sounds horrible.
Racist.
Yeah,
it does.
There's probably,
there's probably a new name for them.
That's why I kept saying red bugs.
Red Bugs.
Yeah.
Geez.
Is there another,
a horrible,
hilarious to show them.
So yeah,
so we're saying,
ah,
that was hilarious.
Yeah.
Super Great.
This is not contrived.
This is not okay though.
Oh
yeah.
That was a ball
goes laughing.
Look at,
I thought it was a gorilla that was secret back legs on that bullet.
Looks like,
my God,
that's two men in a suit,
man.
You're like,
there's a Batman.
That is exactly,
it goes first frame.
Totally shut up.
No,
that's a real bull.
But my question is the bull went back into the shadows and like crushed this
woman and then nobody.
Yeah,
Po and the gun.
Oh yeah.
It comes out.
Well this guy's like,
all right man.
All right,
enough of this.
Get out of here buddy.
Okay.
Dairy comes.
This is terrible.
I just got a cigarette.
Is that the guy,
the bowls owner?
I don't know.
He seems real calm about it.
I mean,
look at that.
He's just smoking.
Is Smoking the smoking guys the best part?
That's the funniest part of the video.
Like he's just the screen.
The woman's,
I don't like the screen.
I like this guy's nonchalant cigarettes.
She's definitely overreacting.
Okeydokey guys.
She is.
She knows there's a camera on the ceiling and she was like,
oh,
they'll do it up for the camera.
Yeah,
I where does it,
how does she
end up guys?
She's in the shadow back there.
They don't care.
Yeah.
They don't care what the thing I,
my experience in that guy doesn't carry either.
By the way.
[inaudible] with bullets that doesn't give a fuck.
And I went,
oh,
videos.
Rarely.
People don't get hurt that bad.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
You got like you watched 10 bull videos,
people getting hit.
Nine times out of 10 they walk.
Yeah.
This lady could still breathe on her own.
That's cause you're watching the Rodeo.
You're not watching like,
you know like Spanish bull running.
Yeah.
Get gored.
She still seems to be her to her lungs are intact and screaming.
She is fun.
Okay,
look who's laughing now.
So I go late joining you guys.
That was unexpected.
I was like,
Oh that was 2019 we don't have is a brace.
It's pretty rare.
We don't even to know.
These guys both voted hilarious.
Oh Gosh.
He's not even fully recovered yet,
guys.
Yeah.
I'm going to go horrible on the go.
Okay.
Not Interested.
All right.
Wait a bum everybody out.
Yeah.
Can we see another one?
This is another one of the bummer.
Definitely.
Let's see what she is.
This one aisle?
Okay.
Hey,
this is like,
this is like the winemaking lady.
It was a fun one.
Here's the thing,
he got the wind knocked out of getting that when knocked out noise.
Here's my theory.
It's,
it's when you don't see anything grow tea.
In other words,
someone got hurt,
but you're not seeing like actual,
yeah.
You know the,
the injury,
right?
Yeah.
And then a noise,
like a grunt or a scream.
The scream.
Fun as the funny guy.
The screams.
Yeah.
There was a delay.
You can't see that his knee is torn to shreds.
Right.
He has no exposed bone.
Yeah.
Is this another angle?
This is a different one.
Video.
Different guy.
Yeah.
Oh No.
Oh,
he's dead.
He died.
The reason I have Travis hilarious,
his second one.
Horrible.
I have trouble.
Nothing.
Just Blah.
Anytime.
I Dunno.
I like,
I'm tall,
I got back problems.
I'm constantly thinking about not getting hurt.
Yeah.
I think 80% of my mental energy at this point in my life is devoted to not
getting hurt.
Moving.
Well moving.
Yeah.
And so when I see that situation and the ice and the snow,
I'm just a,
it's difficult for me to watch about what I w w how I would react.
Yeah.
You know why I like that video.
I don't like people that wear shorts
in the snow.
They dessert.
Yes.
God's punishing them for,
um,
the psycho.
Okay.
I agree with your pants.
It's freezing outside.
What's wrong with pants snowing?
This is the video that started at all
this one.
Oh No.
Oh,
no.
Dope.
Okay.
Ah,
okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
Oh God
lost both at the knees amputated at the knees.
Oh God,
no,
he's fine.
He's fine.
He really is.
They followed it up.
It was a big story in Taiwan.
Yeah.
See,
here's the deal.
He's okay.
Was he driving that thing remotely?
It looked like he was,
he had a remote control.
Oh,
that's interesting.
That's the first thing that I thought
if I was watching that live,
I would react differently.
There's something about the fact that it's been captured and packaged.
That's true.
It makes me think that whatever,
no lie,
this Guy Rick Out,
you would freak it.
Yeah.
Right.
Of course.
Yeah.
I mean,
you laugh,
but then you'd be like,
I got to help them out.
You know,
I would probably just walk over very slowly and then kind of stare down at him,
not unlike that guy.
Right.
Yeah.
That was a crazy reaction rate that just like a slow,
and again,
even moseyed over.
It's like a guy with the cigarettes brothers,
right?
Yeah.
I would have these,
what I would have walked over to the driver,
put my armor like,
you gotta get the fuck out.
The guy on the ground.
This screams just didn't stop enough for a lot to allow me to laugh.
There was,
yeah,
there was no punchline.
Now the lack of the value of human life is interesting.
Like,
what do you mean?
The guy who walks around and he's like hair.
Yeah.
Stone faced.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That was crazy scene.
Where was that?
Um,
bump on the road like,
yeah,
I was a person.
Oh,
there's my ranch.
Who doesn't care?
Cool.
Yeah.
Oh,
now they're showing us another one.
Better do
something.
What?
Oh Gosh.
Ah,
fuck it.
I got her to,
Oh God.
The military is wow.
Oh Gosh.
Well you're the psycho laugh.
I better do something.
Yeah.
Link was affected by that one.
I mean he knew he was coming down too fast.
Yeah.
I think he knew something was wrong with the pair of shoes.
The better do something.
I can't,
I never pinpointed what the something was.
I Dunno what you could do.
I think think he does hit,
I think right before you hit the ground you'd jump
like an appalling elevator.
Ah,
you're supposed to lay flat right in a fallen elevator following fall falling.
You spread yourself as wide as you can.
Laying down on the ground to distribute the load.
Oh you don't stand,
you definitely don't jump cause I don't want to start going to work stand cause
it'll compress your spine.
You get on your back and you spread out.
You're probably going to die anyway.
It's done.
This is the,
I mean if you want to make sure that you're going to die then just do a
handstand.
Does this mean that you,
like,
do you go on Reddit and look at all the twisted twisted stuff?
No,
no,
not at all.
Okay.
So you have a line.
Oh yeah.
I don't,
I don't search for any of this.
So there was a laugh at it when it's presented to you?
I think the,
the,
the points that I pointed out are what I've discovered.
I can,
like if I see someone and you're like,
check this out and this dude's head cracks open like funny to me that that's not
good.
I do think there's something about not seeing any gore.
Yeah.
And hearing yells that does
bring that Tom Likes the screaming sounds Assaf frame.
I get it.
I'm telling you,
cause there's that 50,
50,
a reddit thread where it's like,
I don't go on any of that shit.
Is this a,
you know,
a kid eating an ice cream or is it,
uh,
a monkey getting run over like,
oh yeah.
And I,
and I don't do,
I don't play that game.
How do you even know about it?
Because are the GMM crew made us play,
uh,
like a much,
Oh,
a tame version of that on the show,
but that sort of like a reddit thread and he's either going to be something
really pleasant or really
I've discovered that as,
as much as I laugh at some of this stuff I don't have,
I don't have it in me to watch actual real physical violence or really go,
I can't,
I don't like it.
Right.
But I,
I,
I actually feel like I understand that this realm that,
that we're operating in here,
there's like,
um,
to me I think there's both.
It's not,
you can,
I can be,
I can find parts of it funny and I get the pump parts of it horrendous.
So I think that's the track,
you know,
it's like,
well,
it's supposed to be on the line,
most of it,
you know,
and that's,
that's what I think a lot of people,
they're like this day and age,
you can't find things funny.
You have to,
you have to make a decision.
You're either
going to find something funny or you're going to,
or you're going to be outraged about something.
And it's like,
I,
I think both can be true.
And then you just got to figure out who you trust and let them know that you
find you're funny.
That's right.
That's true.
That's a big part.
I mean,
someone's not the one that talked to,
but yeah,
I tend to just,
just about the violence
videos,
whatever.
Now when it comes to violence,
but when it comes to certain types of comedy,
I don't have a specific example,
but like,
I just think you can be,
again,
you can find something funny and then you can,
do you ever go on?
He fucked?
No.
What is that?
Oh No,
it's a website or what's that?
E F you,
Katie.
Hi.
You guys stepped into the devil's layer.
What is,
okay,
so it's a guy
who,
he is a curator of types that he's actually a talented editor.
I'll give him that.
Okay.
So heal,
it'll heal.
It stays.
It's a lot of adult,
um,
like x rated stuff.
Okay.
But it'll either,
it's,
it falls into different categories within that umbrella.
So some of it will be like big tent.
This is absurd.
Big Tank.
Some of it will be like actual,
um,
you know,
some girl being like,
oh my,
my,
my anal prolapse keeps giving me problems when I'm shooting scenes and it's like
a ridiculous thing like that.
And like I'm an lol genre and then there's like blooper stuff.
Then there's horrendous and stuff like stuff where
don't say it.
It's hard.
Yeah.
It's hard to watch.
Don't say it hard to watch.
You guys aren't into that stuff.
No,
no,
no.
You know what I'm saying?
You should check it out.
I mean,
just
to see what time.
Sometimes some,
some videos or just people crying.
Guys,
what's it like to be normal?
What's it like to not talk about farts all day or should hang out later?
I just have,
do you ever just need to call me?
Oh wait.
Do you have any,
so you've,
you've been here on the show now,
like do you have any,
like you guys are the youtube gods.
What's your advice for us?
I mean,
do we keep the Fart Mike?
Yeah,
you definitely should keep the farm like any other,
like any advice for us,
don't I,
you know,
don't try any harder than you currently are.
Okay.
We don't,
we don't need any competition.
There's,
there's a lot of,
uh,
um,
you know,
how hard do you perceive that they're trying?
How many,
how many,
um,
hours of video are uploaded every second or something and it's increasing every
single day.
Damn.
You can do it.
You're doing your,
uh,
your show every day.
Is it five days a week is five days a week?
Friday we have like a recap show on and how long does that show?
The Monday through Friday.
10 to 15 minutes.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Um,
and we just eat a lot of stuff.
I mean,
it's like,
that's not what the show is intended to be.
It's supposed to be like a creative expression of our,
the conversational nature of our friendship.
But yeah,
we just eat a lot of variously prepared animal testing.
All right.
In a lot of us know what happened.
We got to step into this space.
I don't know what happened.
That's my advice.
Unilock about balls.
Oh yeah.
Do you talk about browning?
You guys eat,
but what about
all the chocolate that comes out of the backside?
Oh,
well yeah,
let's talk about that.
Does it,
does eating crazy food make crazy browns?
No.
Only if only when you do like the hottest pepper in the world,
which we've done it two different times when it was the hardest times.
Well,
when keep releasing new ones,
we're not doing the latest one,
which is like pepper x or sledding.
How horrible is that experience?
Well,
interestingly,
the second hottest pepper in the top five,
I don't know what it is.
Not like we said,
we did a straight up,
uh,
ghost pepper when it was the hottest one.
Horrible experience while it was happening.
Horrible experience for like the next 12 hours or so,
12 hours link link.
He was like,
really?
Like 12 hours later he was like still at ended up and reaper.
So the second one we did the Carolina reaper was the world's hottest pepper.
And we said,
okay,
we're going to set a timer.
I mean all this is on camera.
So we wanted to make sure that the whole experience was captured.
So we didn't add anything out.
And we said,
we're going to set a timer for 10 minutes,
we're going to eat the whole pepper and then we're not going to consume
anything.
No,
I going to drink or eat anything else and we're just going to ride it out.
And so,
uh,
Rhett had this impulse to start destroying the set,
like just became physically violent.
It was very funny.
And um,
it was,
you can see the fear in our eyes at sir.
At a certain point we,
I mean we took the precautions like we had gloves and you know,
cause you don't want to touch your eyes or anything like that.
But we were still crying and I haven't watched it back cause I just don't.
And you were miserable clips of it for 12 hours.
Well on and off,
it's like something shifts and hours,
you know.
Did you eat before you had experience goes away?
Well I,
so I was a little better prepared.
I had a bunch of bananas and like some bread,
but I don't love,
but man,
he didn't go as far.
So what happens on the way out though?
Is it that all miserable again?
The thing is at least twice.
Yeah,
11 o'clock that we,
we've filmed that morning,
11 o'clock that night we were filming something else and in between takes I
would lay down in the fetal position and it,
you know,
I think the way my stomach works is that it does like a major turn every,
it's not constant,
but like I could tell that something happened to every 10 or 15 minutes.
That will be like everything got turned over and it exposed all this heat to
Moses [inaudible] your system that was getting exposed to the oil that pepper
oil is very,
it was very bad.
Terrible.
And um,
know,
and then when it,
I mean all the way out,
it's like it's hot,
hot
and then it,
and then it starts,
it's the same thing that happens when it's going down.
It's like,
am I going to be able to take this?
And you start questioning if you're getting like the worst part when it was
going down was my throat and I thought it could kill you.
Probably.
Am I going to,
am I going to have to tap out?
Are we going to have to like call somebody?
Cause we didn't,
this is before we had like a medic.
We have a medic.
Well what we don't,
we,
we currently don't have a medic.
What happened to them?
We had a medic medic for a while.
We should realize we do have one all the time.
Oh.
But now we've got a lot of,
a lot of our employees are like a CPR training.
You had a medic for whatever you were doing.
We had,
she had a medic for the show.
Yeah.
Youtube funded our show a few seasons back and we made it even longer.
So instead of 15 minutes,
it was a half hour every day.
We did that for a stint.
And because as part of their funding of it,
there was a medic on set.
Right.
And then when that funny funding went away,
we went back to 15 minutes.
Uh,
the medic also went away.
That's true.
And now we're realizing now that the question you have is like,
am I going to be one of those people that has the,
has to go to the hospital because of this?
And then it kind of feels the same way on the way out,
but not like I'm going to have to go to the hospital but like can I,
can I do this?
And it happened and then it happened for me.
It usually happens twice.
It was just funny because we were really depends on your anal prolapse or
whatever though.
Yeah.
I'll send you the link to that.
Well again,
you got to see that way.
We ate the world's,
how does curry,
so what are you guys doing?
So Sean Evans,
the hot ones,
we use your last week.
So we,
the first time we were on,
we were on hot ones like last year,
but the year before that we went to New York and they were doing,
they were on break for the season.
So he's doing these like little one off videos and we went to,
he's the best man.
It's good guy,
a brick lane,
I think curry in New York,
which is named after brick lane in London,
which has got like the ball,
the curry places.
Anyway,
the guys who make the curry there wear gas masks,
water making.
This one a lot is curry in the world and we played a game where you got it
wrong.
He had to take a bite of this curry.
That was bad.
I got to two wrong.
You got four wrong.
Yeah,
but for some reason,
so we were out to dinner with our wives that night,
maybe four hours later.
And uh,
I ended up Rhett left to table giving the table and he never,
and I was like,
I realize it's like,
oh,
now we're eating dessert and stuff.
And he never came back.
And it was like,
and then he comes back to the table and he was like,
he looked,
he looked hard when he's walking funny.
Yeah.
And he was like,
he looked at me and he just said,
you're going to have a rough night.
He knew it just hadn't hit me yet.
I'm assuming it's not solid at that point either.
Right?
You want it to just write out,
but it doesn't,
we don't do that anymore.
So we've kind of gotten to the place where it's like eat.
Cause the last time we did a hot thing,
it was a charity thing and uh,
I eat a Trinidad
Scorpion pepper and it was one of the,
I got,
it got so bad that I was no longer entertaining.
You know,
it's like a place where I was just,
I was mad that we had made the decision to do it.
And at that point I was like,
I can't,
there's no bit here.
I can't find a way to make this funny.
And it wasn't hurting me.
Is,
is bad.
I mean,
you get a different pepper.
You never know.
It was horrible.
So we did,
I saw,
I was like,
I like to think that I was still entertaining.
But you were,
you were very angry,
which was funny.
And the uh,
the hottest one in the world before the a Carolina reaper,
Carolina reapers,
like 2 million Scoville units.
The pepper acts was same guy.
There's some guy in North Carolina,
ed,
something crazy ed or something like that.
And he,
man,
he breeds crossbreeds these peppers.
Where is he?
He's like in the mountains.
What the hub is actually eating these well these pepper head people,
right?
I guess.
And He,
this new one pepper eggs is like 3 million Scoville units in it that come on
man.
No,
that's like,
that's like taking like bear spray and like spraying it.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
Like who's eating these with their dinner?
I mean is that,
it's just all,
so are you guys in a day?
Are you okay?
You got the books coming out,
the novel,
you're touring,
doing live shows were both two in Nashville.
Yeah.
You,
uh,
you have the,
the show five days a week and you're also developing,
do you also continually,
uh,
write and shoot like just a sketch type videos too?
We're,
so we're taking all those,
that whole part of our like creative brain is just into development right now.
There's no way.
We just got too many things going on.
We can't try that on youtube and also try to make it happen elsewhere.
So cause this already too,
too much.
Yeah,
that's a lot as it is.
Speaking of Browns,
I have a,
would you rather for you guys,
it's kind of a game we like to play on the show being that you're foodies and
brownies.
Here we go.
Would you rather for one year all you can eat is taco bell.
Now by this I mean three meals a day,
any items on the menu you can mix and match.
You can take tacos apart and make them in the Omelet.
Whatever the heck right.
For one year.
Well,
you don't have eggs,
you can't make it enough breakfast items now at breakfast.
Um,
okay.
Josh Potter I believe eats there.
Breakfast.
Alright.
Um,
you,
like I said,
you can mix and match,
but it's three meals a day at Taco bell.
Hmm.
Any of easy browns.
I'm talking fours and fives.
Gliders.
Easy.
Like you're healthy.
You're,
they're healthy rounds.
I didn't know what you meant when you said sevens,
but you have a really sloppy is the Bristol stool chart.
Medical Chart.
So a one is like a rock and a sevens.
Just water like the valleys,
threes and fours.
Oh,
so it's a scale of one to seven.
How much?
Fours and fives I am I five again,
kind of loose.
Yeah,
you're five.
Easy peasy,
right?
So you're healthy form.
You may eat anything you want for an entire year,
but every brown,
it's a disaster.
It's like your pepper Brown.
It's like what you had the day of the curry.
That's every day.
That's what you're doing.
But you can,
you want,
you know the,
the bell has the reputation of,
of just tearing you up.
That's what makes it a great.
Now would you rather,
but it seems obvious if you,
if you love Taco Bell,
I mean it's all,
you would choose that for a year.
You said you,
are you saying that that's who you are?
No,
I don't.
I don't hate Taco Bell,
which oftentimes I preferred it.
I refer to Taco Bell is potential spots or Taco bell.
And then I'm like,
that's true.
So I don't,
I don't hate it,
but I don't love it yet.
But I mean the needle could be moved in either direction.
Well,
just be careful if you choose a corporate sponsorship.
We had Mcdonald's sponsored this show and they gave,
they took their money back but plug cause but plug cause oh yeah.
It's a long story.
But um,
I would take the second scenario,
eat anything I want,
but den messy.
Brown's here's why.
Because I have a day at my house,
so do we the toto wash letter a proper be day.
Mine is not.
No,
cause you,
you've got the Todo,
you go.
No,
I was just the one that I just,
my,
my wife got expanders,
put it off.
It's not the whole toilet,
you know,
it's just the,
it's a washlet basically.
So,
and it's,
I don't know what brand it is,
but uh,
it's revolutionary as you already know.
And I would just be like,
I got to get one at work.
I got it.
I got to know if I feel like a real savage without it.
There's probably,
there should be like an APP.
Where's the nearest big day?
As long as I could wash it,
I would be willing to go through the hell that would be those.
Yeah.
Um,
how,
this is a stupid question.
Gross.
Do you guys get on this show?
Like I haven't already figured that out.
I think,
I think you have figured it out and it's a lot grosser than this.
We've been taking it easy.
I need
to ask him private,
but I was asking it to you guys.
Um,
she doesn't eat my scrum.
Is that,
no,
it's about the,
it's about the be day.
So yeah.
I got the fancy schmancy new toilet that like,
y'all walk up to it and it,
it,
it opens,
beckons.
He doesn't speak,
but I mean,
it changes color.
It's not a Todo,
it's the,
it's an American standard,
but it's like,
okay,
maybe it's not as,
it's got all of that stuff,
but with the,
with the day stream,
there's like a,
there's an aggressive stream and then there's an aggressive Washington,
there's like a normal wash.
And then if you hit the button,
yeah,
yes,
it'll,
it'll do like a one of these like oh,
massage pattern.
A water wiping pattern.
Yup.
Wow.
But if you don't,
if you hit it,
if you hit the strong stream once,
it's going to just really hard.
It's going to really rock it.
I like to ride that and ride that.
You build up a tolerance.
You really will.
I'm at that point is if you,
if you line everything up properly,
it's an enema.
Oh Wow.
You can really let it,
it,
the water would have to be visually it looks like the top of red's head right
there.
Gnarly.
It's just hair.
It's got a lot of work.
I'm just fucking fire hose that.
I'll let him run a full cycle goes off on its own and I think,
yeah,
I don't even check what's there.
I'm just saying I know it's a mess.
Just go the dryer.
But what am I trying to get to ask my question?
My question is,
okay,
you kind of answered it,
but can you,
you,
you can use it basically to like
get it in there.
I go in there,
it can go in there and like,
like an Enema,
I sometimes you won't show.
Now here's the thing,
you're,
you're be whole is a very theoretically tight hole.
Right?
You can loosen it.
You sure can,
do you,
but when you're fire hosing your bum,
do you find that the water goes inside your time at home?
Sometimes,
but you know,
you can,
you know,
you can maneuver and positioning yourself.
You can relax.
Yeah,
you can.
You can edge it all.
Colleen.
That's advanced.
That's right.
I don't do any of that.
That's like six to eight months in
advance then because I don't use the dryer that much though.
Like you know,
I don't drive.
No,
no.
So what are you saying?
What's your technique?
You just
breath,
relax and read and aim and just position yourself in the dental.
You get in kind of an internal,
an internal Raasch thorough in there for real.
You like to get in.
But do you do a double tap tap?
So it's one,
it's one.
Ours is the other way.
Double Tangle.
Is that light stream double up?
Powerstream no,
I've got four settings guys.
I've got two buttons.
Oh One is light.
One heavy,
and then if I hit the heavy one twice,
it's gonna like it's going to undulate.
We have an oscillating that's an oscillating feature.
I don't know.
There are different kinds of isolate it.
You know what I mean?
A it,
the stream has been goes like this.
The stream can't waggle what about the light?
The staccato string.
Oh,
you mean where he goes like two to,
I don't like that.
It doesn't move,
so nothing.
The stream bed pressure actually changes on it.
Right?
It goes on off on off like that.
Pulsating is the right word.
Pulsating.
No,
mine doesn't do that.
You need to step it up.
I've seen the subscriber list.
You need to step in right
now.
It's a warm still have a beside each other.
Yeah.
I'm not going to get rid of mine.
I'm just going to add
and that's bawling,
right?
They got,
I got two different companies and I will use them both at once.
I don't know how yet,
but you love it.
You don't do cold water always follows the same time.
I mean,
I think that's why I'm choosing Taco Bell.
Because even with all this apparat tie,
wow.
You don't want,
I mean you don't want to have,
you don't want to,
if you're constantly decimated down there,
then that's a,
that affects everything.
Just washing it off,
not going to make it better.
You're going to have diagnosable
prop and well,
but if you're at the zoo or something like that too,
you know,
that'd be trouble.
He,
you're saying the public dumps would be problematic.
You have to plan your day is,
I mean that's,
it affects you once you had the big day and then you're,
you're at a restaurant.
Yeah.
You know,
and you're like,
they don't,
it's like an animal.
Like you can't,
you can't shut like an animal anymore.
Look,
consider this though.
As much as I love Taco Bell nutritionally,
you might be deprived after one year of eating it three times a day.
I don't know.
I think you'd probably get,
you know,
I think you'd probably get it.
I mean there's so many nutrients,
so many.
I mean,
it all tastes the same eventually,
essentially,
because it's just kind of rearranged in different ways.
The same five ingredients essentially.
[inaudible] beans,
beans alone.
True.
Go a long way.
True cheese.
You get your dairy lettuce,
you get your sour cream.
Tomatoes were considered a fruit.
I don't eat those though.
You don't eat tomatoes?
Tomato sauce.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank God.
Yeah.
Pizza.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay,
but not raw.
He was recently,
or has that come out yet?
I don't think it's come out yet.
Well,
he was,
the world is going with the support.
We won't tell.
What happened was the teaser.
He was hit Matteis to like tomatoes and why can't we?
Can't ruin it.
Well,
that's interesting.
There's a couple a creepy hit.
Incisors are we're going to get into on a future APP.
Yeah.
We found these guys that like the first thought you have maybe have like a
hypnotist.
Can they make people do things and like these guys are straight up creeps.
We're going to,
I'll no moral compass.
That's not a good combination.
They're weird,
weird guys,
but I'm fascinated to see the tomatoes.
I did it.
I did the thing in college at like when they stage.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah,
Totally right.
For what I was doing.
Yeah.
But it started with when he was like,
he was trying to see who was going to participate.
Yeah.
And he's like,
and then like your fall asleep or whatever.
And I just dramatically,
it was like,
you know,
hanging out with him.
Yeah.
Of course.
But I mean in my head I was,
that's what everyone's doing.
Right.
So I don't know.
I was
my only experience and then I've seen one of those shows.
It's a liar.
Yeah.
Sociopathic.
Okay.
Before we go,
I just want to tell everybody,
mythical.com is like home base for everything,
right?
Yup.
mythical.com there's a good mythical morning,
five days a week ear biscuits,
which is the podcast.
Yeah.
Which is once a week.
Yup.
Uh,
written league channel,
which,
um,
you know,
you're not uploading stuff to it right now.
So whatever,
I forget exactly.
A redlink live,
uh,
for tickets alive live that you guys are doing a bunch of dates.
It looks like coming up.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we're,
we're doing,
um,
like every couple of months we go out and hit like a part of the country and do
like,
you know,
four or five shows.
It's awesome,
man.
You guys are killing it and the book's coming out.
Um,
you have,
uh,
smash.
You have the store.
There's just,
it's endless.
You got Development,
Jesus Christ,
man.
Take it easy.
Slow down,
slow down,
and just sit on that day.
That's a long dirt on that big day,
dude.
Get that second bid day you deserve.
Now.
This was a lot of fun.
Thank you guys for coming today.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah,
well I see you in naturally.
You probably take off the next morning,
right?
I don't know what the schedule is.
We'll let,
we'll let you know we come in our latest stick around.
Yeah.
I come in the 10th.
You your shows the ninth.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Yeah man.
All right,
thanks guys.
We'll leave you a,
a special note.
Oh.
Oh,
please do.
All right.
I've got a fun video.
Good morning.
One day,
and
sounds like your group of friends.
It's Super Fun.
A little crazy.
It's got a lot of inside jokes.
Thanks guys.
Hi Mommy.
Thanks genes.
Thank you for watching this episode of your mom's house,
and if you had a great time,
watch more videos here,
here,
here.
Don't forget to subscribe here,
here,
so that you will know when your mom's house video comes out immediately.
Thanks Jean.